all right
we are here it is time
and we are live the witch queen edition
the moment what's going on the last word
law incognito ebontis thai guy travis
and an amazing special returning guest
as always but let's start with my man e
how are we doing we are here the witch
queen
um yeah minimal sleep lots of hours
staring at my computer and honestly
having a blast so i'm having a good time
i don't i was like there's other things
happening on the screen right now so
people have seen me stream a lot in the
last couple of days we will talk about
our thoughts on everything uh travis i
need explanations about everything
happening on the screen and if you are
an audio listener we have thai guy
travis please go find this on audio if
you or video
yes tie guy travis
in a tuxedo i'm pretty sure holding a
flute of champagne so travis take it
away sir
yeah well i don't know if you guys knew
this but my wardrobe over the years has
been purely determined by how good
destiny is at the time
and that makes a lot of sense i like
that yeah you guys didn't know this but
the entire year of the taking king i
wore this every day and then it sort of
kind of went up and down over the years
but now i'm back at the tuxedo um so
yeah it's been a great week we eaten out
here
oh it's been good this day is delicious
it's been absolutely delicious like uh
like a glass of champagne fluted
champagne so uh
it's been very good shall i introduce
our guests here today please yes please
by all means
okay yeah i'd like to introduce our
guest but first i actually have a little
bit of a personal story
i thought that i would share um with the
group here let's see if i can find it
dude
no idea what's happening everybody this
is we're off the rails well this is
great so somebody uh sent me
some codes
for uh emblems and destiny they just
sent me some codes here i got it on
twitter um and i was so surprised i was
like oh thank you so much like these are
these are the codes that you get for
emblems that you maybe get on the store
or whatever
and i said oh thanks so much i really
appreciate it and he said no problem
always a pleasure
uh thank you so much for the content
that you've produced it's helped me a
lot for years
uh i miss seeing you on fire team chat
and hope that you were doing well
and i was
very touched by this and then he ended
it with thanks mr tassie
[Laughter]
so uh
just wanted to share that as the intro
for our guest paul tassie here uh so
what you're saying is you owe me some
codes what i'm saying is i used some
codes before
i'm saying i probably owe you some codes
that i use that we're supposed to give
you how how would that have happened is
what i'm wondering is it like travis and
tassie somebody got a email link kind of
disconnected or something maybe he just
thought we were each other the whole
time i i don't know
maybe he just thought you were paul
tassie the entire time of our team chat
he never read the names at the bottom
possibly i don't i don't know maybe he
really was trying to say you meant a lot
to him we'll go with that
hilarious but anyway uh i i think that
serves as as much of an introduction as
you'll need to to welcome our honored
guest paul friend of the show
former fire team chat member possibly
future fire team chat member if we can
get our stuff together we'll see
let's see we'll see
that one's also going to be coming hot
in hot like the 12 we don't even have
yet we don't have to i'm referring
ukraine about donating money from game
to give uh for the next four to eight
hours to them yep okay so that's nice
yeah i can read it our hearts and our
our hearts are with our friends and
families by the offense affected by the
events in ukraine we would be donating
100 of the proceeds for the first 48
hours of our game to give drive to
humanitarian aid
uh two
humanitarian oh eight efforts going in
response
to the conflict and there's different
links for direct relief voices of
children and international rescue
communities so check the link out very
good things obviously if you guys aren't
paying attention to the news there's uh
some issues going on in the world
so issue yeah or yeah some people pretty
much yeah yeah
it was um yeah it escalated yesterday so
say the least
trying not to get too much swap this one
yeah yeah i was like i'm guessing
honestly i was honestly wondering if
they weren't going to do the twab
because we already have enough to talk
about there's probably not too much
besides yeah some things are broken
we're working on them we know it and
other than that um yeah so
i didn't think about that but yeah lots
of uh lots of brands are doing a social
media silence today including possibly
yet it could be internally maybe try to
make a decision maybe not to to do it in
lieu of the events that's about yeah
anything about that probably not too
much crucial that they need to tell us
that we don't already have in our hands
as it is it's not like hey by the way
here's void 3.0 you've been playing with
it for a couple days right and they
might not want to celebrate be like oh
we got all these concurrent players
right you know good because it's all
good news obviously so
maybe they'll just yeah maybe they'll
hold off yeah
plenty to talk about plenty to talk
about well
it has been um
so before we get started
i wanted to see if i can have a little
fun with the podcast
now with those of you that are listening
um spoilers if you're wondering about
that we are going to keep spoilers to
as much of a minimum as possible
especially like second half of the story
anything much later any big reveals
anything of that nature we will do that
and give you guys kind of an audio
warning for it i will also try and
possibly cut in it might sound weird to
be like spoilers at whenever so if you
want to jump ahead or skip it you will
know but before we get to our discussion
about the giant expansion of which queen
season of the
risen that launched recently i wanted to
ask and see because i've heard a lot of
amazing comments and things on twitter
and stuff like that and then a little
while ago we also got a game that had
some fun comments and things with
regards to my hosts
and i wanted to say if you had to pick
one or the other
destiny 2 witch queen campaign halo
infinite campaign what do you pick
oh this interesting pitch queen oh come
on
that's interesting
but
no i mean granted this is something
about a bias just given how invested i
am in destiny but i gotta say witch
queen in terms of how it moved the story
forward
like i i i had fun during infinite and
like there were some good moments but
like to be infinite just in the grand
scheme the halo universe kind of felt
like
either like like a postscript to halo 5
or like a an intro to what would have
been halo 6 like
you don't really make that much progress
i don't think over the course of that
story and
i i don't know i i think there's more to
come with with infinite and like kind of
as an ongoing story but
i i don't think they're particularly
close if you ask me i know i had some
pretty high marks from my other hosts so
that's why i wanted these two to see if
they can make a call but before we do
david james orris hey guys big fan long
time listener witch queen was great just
like all of you i'll post my ign score
later this week ign is important glave
news
and then also two dollars always be
glavin
he is a huge glade flash shout out to dj
we will rock commenting on every the
post i make on twitter about glaives yes
he's
a huge fan of evangelism yeah
so let's go cognito first
what's your i gotta know xbox guy
destiny guy you're trying to make me
pick between my kids yes exactly i
thought it'd be hilarious here's the
thing the context paul said it
best
halo infinite is a return to form halo
infinite is
them getting back on track but
the reality is five
you know there was some things that
narratively people didn't desire
including myself so to me this was like
making things right having a cohesive
thing now we're setting up you know the
future for for halo that's fine
destiny is like which queen is like
endgame like this is like all the
narrative threads
built to this moment and i don't know if
we're going to touch it but it's like
i'm not going to spoil yeah
execution
and the scale
felt earned like this this this led to
what i felt for the most part great
execution and this is bungie
storytelling for the most part you know
a tier so
sorry okay
before i give it to travis let me ask
you this then because i knew that kind
of might be the way this goes
is this the best campaign from bungie
oh that's a good one that's a good one
that now it's new it's fresh i don't
want to recently be a prisoner at the
moment because i just did it
i mean man it's it's really good though
it's really good
the the reason why it's still incomplete
and and again we talked all right
yes
because at the end of the list we know
paul levy paul we talked we know
bungie's gonna make a great rate i'm not
worried about the raid being not great
is that part of the campaign though
i consider it it is the story ties to it
like i mean last wish i think so last
wish in i would say like
was the kind of final piece of where the
campaign led to it was part of the story
i would say in my head everybody reviews
it differently i i just my personal
review i feel like
i've always hated when the raids were
disconnected and they had really no
narrative continuity like when taking
king kong introduced and forsaken
continued that is huge for me and i'm
pretty confident this is going to lead
into it but it's just a matter of okay
we do have taken king out there we do
have you know the last witch ray that
led from the dreaming city and how that
was so well done and woven so we just
got to see the execution of what happens
but
incomplete i can't i can't say that yet
until i get that so but as far as your
first question yeah i gotta go with the
recency bias and i gotta go which group
i'm curious for travis because travis
loves both too yeah where's his children
yeah i love both both of them i'm super
deep in the lore of both of them and uh
so my high marks for halo infinite were
sort of two prong i actually i really
liked the campaign but
uh and especially the fact that it
changed its formula up and was open
world and all that stuff but uh not a
lot of the reason i loved it was due to
its story particularly
and i think that's just because the halo
story and the destiny story are both
really convoluted and unless you keep up
with them they don't really make sense
to you and i'm sure most people probably
aren't going to get a lot of the witch
queen campaign regardless just because
if you're not if you're not really in
the lore it's it's hard to follow and
that's evidenced by the fact that i
played it with somebody who's super not
in the lore and they were kind of like
well what's going on like a lot of the
time you know uh yeah so it it can be
hard i actually think halo and and uh
destiny have that problem in common so
so bungie has that problem
yeah part of the reason that i thought
hey yeah part of the reason i thought
halo infinite was one of the best
packages you could get is because the
multiplayer was also like almost
flawless like it was like incredibly
good and and as a package is a great
game but uh
i would say it's really hard to compare
the two if you're just going by story i
would say witch queen definitely has it
like like to paul's point uh the halo
infinite is a lot of setup it's kind of
like the first chapter and destiny
benefits from having years of setup and
also a live service where they can kind
of build it incrementally over the week
so i would say when it comes to story
it's better in terms of the actual like
gameplay during the campaign probably
halo honestly uh and that's just because
i think the the halo sandbox and
mechanics and shooting are just like top
notch but it like it's hard to know what
you mean when you say campaign because
like if if you would consider the raid
part of the campaign which i wouldn't uh
then then that's like a whole separate
conversation of like you know is there
end game in the halo infinite campaign
like no not really you can play
legendary
even taking that out yeah we're really
comparing apples to oranges i'm i'm a
critic and that i can i tell you if a
game is good or bad but i i'm really not
accustomed to comparing a game to
another game that's not really like in
my skill set i guess but they're both
fantastic i think we can agree and
they're both yeah absolutely they're
both high marks for
uh the studios that made them um i would
say
i would say it's not the best campaign
that bungie's made though i still think
that goes to halo 2.
personally that's it okay
that's what i was like i thought that'd
be a fun kickoff just because i know
like huge halo fans bungie
campaigns been through a lot so i just
thought it'd be a funny one to kick off
uh i want to go to paul first as now
we'll talk into which queen and
whether it's 30 000 foot view your
favorite thing
so far at this point we are going to
bounce around everywhere so i am sorry
for those who look forward to time
stamps paul yeah just just let it out um
if you've already haven't done it in
your you know 20 30 minutes of videos
that you've done already well i was
going to do a 12 video today so i didn't
do one
so i got plenty plenty to say uh so just
kind of an overview of where i'm at i
did my first run through on normal just
really quick i wanted to get through all
the story beats before people started
spoiling it for me which was bound to
happen uh so i did that on day one i
just wrapped up a legendary campaign run
solo on my titan it's a second run um
as of like an hour ago
and so i got that experience i have done
the parasite exotic quest and my highest
character is only like 15
close to like 15 30 15 27 something like
that
so i haven't progressed some of the
other higher things that you need to be
like closer to 1550 for
um i've gotten pretty deep into the
throne world leveling up i just unlocked
the ability to do like master
uh well heroic legend and master
campaign missions which
13. is that where you are it's 13. i
mean i like the exact same spot that's
crazy
yeah yeah yeah because you get a lot of
xp running the campaign itself so that
really helps level you up oh interesting
so that's kind of yeah i've experienced
a good amount of this obviously done
weapon crafting only have used void 3.0
uh i am deeply deeply impressed with
99.9 of every
percent of everything i've seen here uh
i i certainly think this is we can do
debate like bungie or halo or the grand
history but this is this is destiny's
best campaign for sure i i don't think
it is
especially close like i i know everybody
loves
the taken king and i think the taking
king is a very good expansion and it was
a totally
transformative experience um for destiny
compared to obviously vanilla so like
the difference between taking king and
vanilla d1 was probably bigger than the
gap between last year of destiny 2 and
witch queen but last year of destiny 2
was awesome so you know it's it's the
series itself has progressed to a point
um where you know those kind of huge
leaps forward equality are hard and yet
i still think they managed to
do a lot of that here and the decision
to focus as much as they did on the
campaign
and the campaign missions and still
there's a bunch of bonus stuff even
besides that happening
i think that was absolutely the right
call i think everyone is very very
satisfied with how the campaign went up
both narratively
in terms of we'll get into that later
with the story stuff but also in terms
of how it plays people were really
really enjoying their legendary
playthroughs of it i'm not really a big
like solo dungeon person like and you
know try this encounter 300 times and
tear your hair out this was like the
right balance of challenge to me like i
i'm not that hardcore but i still don't
really love that you can just steamroll
through a story and just like you're
almost like just sprinting through it
like it's a strike or something and
i i liked having to play tactically
having to think about the builds i was
using
but it's still not so difficult it's
like okay you need to be in like you
need to have the gm
meta build to like get through it and
like perfect teamwork um you can do it
solo i did it solo you know i i've heard
all sorts of different loadouts that
people have used to to make it to the
end
uh i had my buddy the glaive with me the
whole time
i can get into later but i think it was
it was very important both in kind of
the scale and the scope of the campaign
and the fact that they designed it
around
being played over and over again because
it's not just a legend run now again
this is a farmable
activity for pinnacle drops for weapon
crafting materials and things like that
so if this is something we're going to
keep coming back to you like it's crazy
to me that you couldn't replay
the past story conventions a lot of
games are doing this now halo infinite
you can't replay the campaign like
going back to individual missions or
things
so it this is not the most common thing
anymore so i i think this is
it was kind of a risk because if the
campaign didn't deliver then all that
work would have been kind of pointless
and we'd be like well i don't wanna i
don't wanna play that again like forget
it but i think it really it really paid
off and they did a fantastic job so
that'll be my my intro thoughts here
travis
yeah
um i generally agree i mean i i think uh
you know the taking king was the biggest
leap forward destiny will probably ever
get but that's mostly due to the fact
that destiny vanilla was not great um
aside from the the raid the notable
exception of the raid it was in a really
bad spot and they fixed a ton and made
it more of an rpg but i think as you
know in the age of incrementally better
destiny expansions the witch queen is
without a doubt the best campaign
uh it's got the best um
economy that we've seen in a while like
things are kind of stable you know
you're getting uh it's fun to do things
like
grind the deep site weapons and i find
myself you know in the past i wasn't
really looking for the god rules but now
i'm i find myself grinding the
wellspring activity because i want to
get the tarnation to drop as a deep
sight weapon right so that i can
craft my own one and then level it up
and so there's sort of like a very cool
loop for the hardcore people
really my only complaints so far are you
know it's one of the buggier destiny
releases similar to beyond light it's
got some things that are a little bit
wonky and uh
you know certain activities have
glitched out on me and stuff and uh and
then the second thing is that just that
the economy is extremely
unapproachable like the game is probably
as unapproachable as it's ever been in
its current state just because it's got
now weapon crafting is like yet another
layer of like crazy complexity on it for
people that haven't played it and it's
really hard to understand the story if
you haven't kept up with it and all of
those things so yeah there's like six
currencies that was wrong so yeah
they're playing two they're playing to
their uh
their their core base right which i
think is great and and for people like
you and i we're gonna eat it up and and
and be really happy but i do worry about
uh new players trying to figure it out
i'm also as always i'm annoyed by some
small things like i really hate the fact
that i can't see how much uh uh ruinous
alloy i have i'm just gonna say that i
was like
to check that there's no place
that's the only thing i can think of
i i don't understand the reason why but
yeah it's it's really a bizarre choice
and it it adds to the confusion because
then you're now you're grinding for this
material that you don't even know what
you have you have to go back to the
relic to check if you have enough for it
and it's crazy so i i have like little
complaints by that but like on the whole
the story was absolutely fantastic it
was so good to see them using some of
the lore that they've been building up
for years um the game plays extremely
well uh i i have a hard time using the
solar or arc subclasses now i'll tell
you that like those are frozen
it's brutal yeah yeah i've used both of
them since uh the dlc came out because i
just kind of wanted to compare you know
and contrast and like you know you
throwing hammers feels awful like it's
like so much worse than than using the
the new classes because there's so much
more void overshield titan wall is just
like oh yeah i thought that's like
i i went to my ark subclass i put up a
wall i'm like oh damn
i don't know i have no idea how they're
gonna make those
relevant and i'm very curious to see
what they do but i mean one of them six
months away from right now probably it
seems like so it is yeah probably it's
gonna be about they said they said
they're gonna do all three over the
course of the next year right is that
what they're yeah their plans yeah yeah
i mean i'd be surprised if it was well
we don't even know how long this season
is three months they said may 24th they
oh they did say that yeah
stuff
okay okay but they're so they're
supposed to get right like there's not a
road map they stopped doing that but
they uh i think because they kept making
promises and then having to push them
back but they're usually pretty good
about hitting roadmap targets i thought
better than most
other games there are things that were
on the roadmap that they still haven't
done like uh the adding the catalysts
for the ones that weren't there and oh i
just meant like the seasonal road map
not like the overarching i know what
you're talking about we have to get done
the photo
yeah i was talking about yeah i was
talking about the old romance they used
to do we're like going to do this by
june and stuff those were awful yeah
yeah um
but yeah so we don't have a road map but
uh the the one thing i will say that is
like the big thing that i think that
that that is a knock against the witch
queen is the stuff it doesn't have
that's like like it doesn't do anything
for for crucible it the the gambit fixes
i think are not sufficient like the
stuff that you've played stuff that's
sort of i haven't even yeah yeah
it's yeah
the fact that the fact that the strike
play list is still pretty limited and
contains the old strikes and there's
just stuff that like is still wrong with
destiny's battlegrounds all right
battlegrounds in there i like that they
added the battlegrounds it's something
like and they took the champions out and
they're just yellow bars now and like
yeah it's it's certainly a good idea um
but obviously we you know we would just
like more more strikes and more exactly
yeah like empire hunts should still be
in there i'm going to stand by that one
i'm with you i agree i don't know why
they're not in there it's like it's a
year
it's part of beyond light i think so
they don't want to like the separation
i mean they're probably going to make
beyonce free at some point so
that'll be a few years
yeah
yeah that's sort of that's sort of the
like if you're just looking at the
content that that is like the meat of
this expansion and you're just looking
at the the content that you're playing
the campaign and the exploring the open
world it's it's fantastic really hard to
be it's more the ecosystem around it and
the stuff that still is in kind of a
dire state that i'm that i'm you know
more critical on but yeah i have very
few complaints about the content i've
played so far which is which is great
yo
they did it man they did it they did it
for me um
i just fired it up and the first thing i
thought about was
ue and his friend in a sense of the
storyboard stuff
and i'm thinking of a new player who
let's be honest you know destiny's law
especially hive law could get really
intense and i love this setup okay how
did we get here what's going on and then
we dive in first thing off the bat um
the sky boxes
some of the things that you see in the
throne world a lot of decadence a lot of
elegance you know what i'm saying like
it was really cool a lot of
transitioning between different worlds
and sandboxes that i really liked as far
as like paul said it i went immediately
to void because i said you know what i'm
going to put it on legendary i want to
really test 3.0 to see how effective it
is on this quote-unquote nightfall level
you know kind of difficulty and i was
very impressed it was that perfect
balance and this is what we've always
wanted because the problem with destiny
prior campaigns as good as they are when
you go through and steamroll and you
squash it doesn't feel good then on top
of that you can't replay it and to
travis's point i did encounter some
really awful bugs where you know
you got the boss and i glitched out and
i'm like no and then what was so cool we
were so nervous because some of those
mechanics in these fights were really
intense you know especially there's a
guy when you go down and he's kind of
circling he's kind of giving you d1
um what is it allah ghoul in the in the
dark kind of thing but um
yeah give you dark blade vibe there's
one part now and khan was pretty pretty
brutal but the thing about it that i
love that the glitch happened
and when i went back i was so happy to
see almost like that raid three-quarter
length circle saying that you're
three-fourths of the way and it went
right back and i say yes yes so
checkpoints
the the campaign is meaty it is meaty
these stage they're long they're lengthy
on the characters that you you face are
great and the thing that i realized the
difference with the story
with the loose and brood having the
light is transformative because
you have tactical decisions you have to
make now on the battlefield if you take
out that hive you know that's using
thunder that's a witch or whatever
first and this they're protected and you
don't get to that ghost and finish that
goes you end up cursing yourself like
you've got to be tactical and that's the
part i was just smiling like okay this
is truly transformative not just okay
yeah they're using our powers but if you
don't finish them it can be really
detrimental to you in the mission so
story lords phenomenal i gotta shout out
my voidlocks 3.0 with sean and e i'm
loving it
you know i was using the um the riff for
devour almost as a weakening for bosses
so i'll dps set up the weaken effect you
know go into that shout out to having
melees that can do the volatility effect
that could blow people up uh again what
paul was saying in reference to
different builds and loadouts the
glaives are outside i see people with
deglaze i actually went back to an old
school ignition code with blinding
grenades and kind of really stunning
people but i just felt the difficulty
everything felt earned and then when i
got to that ending part and obviously
we're not going to do spoils and stuff
like that i'm like okay i see where
they're going i'm getting my end game
moments i'm getting characters that i'm
new characters older characters a lot of
stuff i still i have one complaint
though as far as
i would have liked
some of the end game
characters some of them to be
more voiced when they were all on screen
yeah but that's just a nitpick but other
than that look they did it as far as the
um the actual like weapon craft i didn't
dive too much into it but the system so
far okay uh oh i got to get them though
trav
can they stop
yelling at me taking up 30 to 40 of my
screen
to tell me make sure you go and inspect
the glaive then use the deep residue i'm
like okay bungie okay can i get this off
my screen yeah
it's funny because one of the main
problems of destiny right now is that
it's it's really hard to learn how to
play the game and their solution to
doing it is like what is really
obnoxious and probably not super helpful
to the people who need to learn it so
yeah
but i'll give it to you i got so much
though but the overall consensus is
they did it
this is yes by far in my opinion
the best campaign i was so satisfied and
yeah i'm looking forward to where this
is going to go but i'm curious man i saw
you rocking so you rock like where yeah
you're the soloist so i'm curious too
yeah so first thing uh took my titan
soloed the whole thing on legendary from
the start on stream
i was about 12 hours i think from the go
for me
and basically i was like i don't know
what i'm gonna face in any encounter so
arbalist was my crutch any shield i was
covered
didn't matter what it was
uh i ended up using a bow just i love
bows
whenever bungie put bows in destiny they
like they have been attached to to my
hip because it's that high damage point
on miners and i can always usually get
that crit they do have a lot of aim
assist don't don't give me sometimes so
much aim assist they will hit a wall
even though you're trying not to hit
like you're trying to hit a leg
um so and then just ascendancy so i had
the tracking rocket launcher uh i had my
threaded needle for most of it and then
if i needed if it was more hive than arc
my wolf tone draw i've got like frenzy
and archer's tempo on that thing and
it's kind of just perfect so
that was basically my loadout for the
entire thing
i never really took much of it off i
just switched between a couple bows
rocket launcher and arboles the whole
way through void 3.0 the whole way
did you use upgrade modules
oh hell yes i used upgraded
thank you that was for me the double
chest and giving me two upgrade let me
stay stylish i was so happy i was so
proud to hear you say that continue i
just wanted to make sure my weapons came
with me they were more important but
yeah yes exactly i was upgrading
constantly yes
um i mean i probably did it to a point
where i was upgrading too much where i
wanted to go buy some more
mine was not about looks mine was just
like keeping everything up to level
because i was going legend solo i'm like
i need to be as high as possible that
was my main reason to make sure i was up
to level i wasn't about looks either but
it's it's hard it's hard power cap
though so you couldn't like over level
yeah you could only get to the point
where it was like the minimum for the
next one i think so it wasn't like a ton
of time but yeah you want to you want to
keep your uh your build your stats your
build yeah
you're right i didn't do the arm i
listened to you with armor but i did
what you said it was that that efficient
bill continued i'm sorry no uh and then
it was just like the big jump from three
to four it went from like 1350 like 14
20 like that was like the one big jump
and everything creeped
no i mean
we went through it live on stream had a
huge number of people watching that day
for me at least i mean obviously not
like glad with thousands of people but
i mean i enjoyed every minute of that
thing the the lore the voice acting some
of the people that we got introduced to
uh new characters as you said old
characters the way the lore was done
to get in as we said the animated
storyboards we talk i've said it
multiple times we got more of those you
get to see the history of
you know the main antagonist we get more
there the cinematics
dude like off the charts for clifton
cliff scene really
but yeah i mean there were
yeah the i will say yeah deborah wilson
amazing amazing job shout out to her she
was also blowing it up on twitter
uh yeah deborah wilson on twitter got
called if you've been personally
insulted by sabbath in here no no that's
not yeah
that was that's the thing she'll forever
be known as paul grassy yeah yeah
until forever until the next meme that
comes up yeah yeah yeah true the little
troll
that was like extra and i was like wow
she was actually with you
part of the joke
no that wasn't even that wasn't even in
the script she just she did
she ad-libbed that yeah yeah that was
pretty um but yeah i mean going through
the journey
um had a couple of random deaths here
and there but like the checkpoints were
really nice it wasn't rally banners it
was like campaign banners so you're
going into basically every encounter
full ammo which never had to worry about
which was amazing uh what did you think
the hardest part was in legend solo oh
good question for me the finale
yeah
okay
tough the third mission ghost is where i
saw a lot of comments on my videos
because i gave like one of my first
videos just like tips on legendary and a
lot of them were asking like i'm just
the mission is that it's three it's the
one in the dark
it's one of the dark with increased
melee damage with this guy who slams the
fire thing down at you
oh my god
one legend that is we didn't have that
one i died during that part i still only
probably died like i don't know ten
times in that but that was i was the
hardest for that one for me that one i
didn't die at all but i was like i died
many times too sad that's amazing yeah
it was like that one i didn't die at all
for whatever reason i only died i only
died once the sabbath dude
that was the funny that's the weird
thing when you talk to enough people
there's always like you're good at this
thing and this thing it's like for me
running i've i've soloed the dark blade
strike too many times i guess i'm just
you like kind of used to kiting and
running i was like i don't know that's
just one of those things i was like i
kind of got the concept but it was like
there were moments where i was like that
close so i mean it was more just like
pucker real fast and hope you get
through it but um yeah it was close but
no sabathan it was just a moment to
where tried to get too aggressive okay
no and then trying to figure out how
much damage you could get in then kind
of figuring out the mechanics when it
came to what was going on but um
like
just the whole journey through
everything
as you guys said void 3.0 makes the
other classes look i don't want to play
them
i i want the i mean we get a tease of
possibly what one of them may look like
but that's all i'm gonna say
um one of the future subclasses without
saying too much
crafting
is going to be
it's gonna be a long grind but it is
nice to have a path for the hardcore i
think travis said it well the hardcore
will have a path
and then potentially
even more so if you spend the time with
something but it is going to be some of
it's probably going to feel like a
tedious journey i can guess
but i do like the idea of it the glaive
has been fun i've been actually leaning
to that more after the campaign
uh and then we get into what's going on
with the season and everything else i
mean i'm
i'm over the moon for it so i mean of
course
like i would probably be able to have to
nitpick at some but i mean for me when i
was wondering it's like what am i gonna
what would i rate this thing for me i
would probably rate it like a nine
so i mean it's not perfect it's a little
rough around a couple edges as travis
said there's things
older systems that still need work but
for what we got
oh like almost everything i could hope
for so i mean that's nice general top
i was gonna ask all of you um how did
you guys feel generally
because i felt like there was a good
diversity of mechanics in this one but
like how did you guys feel did you guys
feel like hey these are cool encounters
just kind of mechanic level like how did
you feel overall as far as what they
brought
there were mechanics first of all i was
so happy in the story campaign i did
something they talked about before this
but and they said they were going to do
this but
you know it normally campaigns it's like
the most complicated they make things or
like dunk this orb in this very obvious
orb dunking spot or defend against three
waves of enemies while a door unlocks
here there were like actual mechanics
that you had to figure out
or google the guide if you really
couldn't but and those got kind of
increasingly more complex as time went
on like i i really like the one in the
final mission where i won't get into
spoilers yet but it's like for the final
you had to like really like pay
attention to symbols and like figure out
how to navigate that giant space and
they did not give you any hints
so that took it was both combat but also
you had to figure out like what the hell
was going on and there are a couple
sections like that
that i thought they did really well but
it's it you know it was tough enough to
be interesting but not like obviously
full raid mechanics that are going to
like just drive you nuts
did you guys have it your little names
for them snow cone star
i've had those since oh god what is that
pit of heresy yeah yeah
yeah you got like ice cream cone and
hamburger and i've got like double
equals and i've got all my weird stuff
turret guy yeah it's like apparently we
do actually have oh
do a rad thank you brother he's a mvp in
the chat hey they really they actually
did this one mvp
yeah uh he might have actually tagged me
in discord because it's actually
sometimes there faster
there it is
yes oh okay
um okay well that's a decently high
overall necromancer what's the biggest
thing you feel missing from the witch
queen expansion you guys take that i'm
gonna give a look over the top see if
it's worth talking about biggest thing
you think might be missing lacking or
just you know if you've got a critique
or something like that uh the critique
or travis you get to go first on that
one of course
yeah i kind of already talked about it
but yeah the the things that they're
missing i think are the things that
aren't the campaign like if you're just
paying for a witch queen campaign that's
great but i you know i view kind of the
big expansions as you're paying for
this this destiny ecosystem for the next
year right like that's the thing that
you're getting and the ecosystem we have
right now is lacking in two-thirds of
the areas right like the pve folks are
are killing it and then the poor gambit
people are
are dealing with the fact that
their mode is basically abandoned and
also that they have to play gambit and
then uh the the crucible people uh are
still in the situation that they've been
in for you know the better part of like
two years where there's not a ton of
content geared toward them and there's
especially not any new content geared
toward them we have the promise of some
new maps down the road but none of that
is in the game right now so it's it's uh
you know pretty minimal
also the sandbox is
it feels weird to cr to critique this
but it is a real criticism which is
um
the sandbox is very unbalanced right now
like i said at the top like you can't
really play as solar or arc anymore
because they're not on the 3.0 version
and that that is weird it's weird and
crucible when things get competitive but
it's also weird to see the lack of
diversity in the open world everyone's
using void some people are using uh you
know the the um stasis but no one's
using solar or uh
or um arc and first we saw like drop a
well and a strike and i was like what
yeah right
what are you doing
it's so weird yeah and i think that is a
that is a knock against the game right
like currently the sandbox feels very
unfinished and and like you have to play
it a certain way to really play it right
and i think that's uh that's you know a
fair criticism but obviously they're
going to change it but but right now
we're kind of not really there so i i
could go on i i have i have a fair
amount of criticism about about the the
game overall but it's not really
anything you guys haven't heard before
right it's just the stuff that they
haven't gotten around to fixing yet
but yeah i don't have that much to say
negative about uh the content i've
played the witch queen is great i am sad
that there's no secret secondary
location i was still
hoping that there would be something
like that but
stuff may happen after i think something
happen after the raid but yeah probably
not a whole lot probably not a whole new
location yeah yeah probably not a whole
new one the map is a lot bigger that's
another thing we haven't touched the map
is a lot bigger than i think it looks
yeah like it's if you just look at the
actual map with the three zones there's
only one drop point it looks kind of
like the dreaming city but it is huge in
all the areas that you go to for the
campaign and you go back to for
different missions and things and there
are you know different areas that unlock
through the quest and stuff so i i think
it is kind of deceptively large and it's
not just like okay we got a new dreaming
city section i think it is more
substantive than that
um in terms of my critique
i may end up writing something about
this so i well i'm very appreciative of
many aspects of crafting some things
with crafting are kind of weird up front
here like this may
change as the economy kind of evolves
and stuff but so i've already found
myself running into i've hit the
currency caps on all of the alloys the
the base ones um which
so it's like 250 for each of those and
as far as i can tell the only way you
use those i i'm pretty sure is for
the advanced uh perks or like sometimes
you have to spend them for the strika
catalyst or something but like there's
no other way
to to use those and yet i have two
ascendant alloys and i i only just maybe
unlock something that can maybe start
farming them so like i can't use any of
this capped currency that i kept in you
know a day and a half here and i'm like
do i do i put the stuff in my vault um
and yet like the other currency that i
need the the base one the neutral
element i can't really get enough of
that and like i don't have enough to
craft everything i want for that because
um i keep spending it on things and like
even unlocking one new perk is about
you know a a weapon and a half of deep
sight
uh there's a lot of like
kind of weird and annoying rng things
with with crafting so like they wanted
to give like the crafting mechanic
itself is not rng but so like i need
this tarnation grenade launcher to
progress
uh one of the end quests forward that
drops from
the uh
whatever the activity is called um well
spring well
from the wellspring on maybe defend days
i'm not sure how that rotates but it was
dropping for the past day but i i not
only need it to drop where it's a pretty
low chance of a drop i'd say one out of
three or one out of four times but i
also need it to drop with deep sight and
then i need the deep sight to be for the
pattern and then i have to get the
pattern like so many three times
so it's like
it's it's still a good amount of rng to
even like get that bass line and once i
have that like great okay maybe i'm
ready to go then but
getting that at least for some of these
weapons feels a little bit odd uh and
then the final thing about crafting i'm
finding a little weird is like
it so i i got like a essentially a god
roll of the
the new pulse it can roll with um it's
soros pulse can roll without a headstone
yeah yeah and so i got that it's like i
don't know four out of five at least
and
so i'm like okay do i need to craft this
and like so technically you do need to
craft it because you're gonna you're
gonna want enhanced outlaw an enhanced
headstone right but in order to do that
i would have to craft a soros pulse
rifle with garbage perks
and only use that pulse rifle until i
unlock outlaw and headstone and if i'm
playing with the outlaw and headstone
one i'm not making any progress at all
toward my crafted one so like it feels
like all the weapons under the same type
should kind of
contribute to the same pool somehow but
like it doesn't work like that it's you
have to stick with only the crafted ones
so what i'm finding now is like i have
crafted versions of like three weapons
on me at all times that are just
truly terrible rolls until i can unlock
the better rolled version of them even
if i have another role that has dropped
already
that is is a better role than the one
i'm using so like it's it doesn't really
mesh like our the rng of random drops
that the game has always had doesn't
quite fully match with this new crafting
system and like again maybe this will
get better as time goes on but that's
something i've noticed here at the
beginning yeah that's that's one of the
things i've known i've i've kind of had
a complaint about the other thing is
that
you don't really get to choose your
weapons in in this expansion at all like
whether you're using a deep sight weapon
just to grind it up until you you can uh
you know grab the materials from it or
whether you're using a weapon that you
crafted that has perks that you do not
want that you're just trying to get
through 30 levels so that you can get
the version that you want right like
it's it's so much grinding you're like i
i
constantly am finding that my
loadout is not dictated by me it's
dictated by like what i need right so
i'm like all right i have to use this
glaive weapon because i'm trying to get
it to 30. i've got a deep sight weapon
up here and then my power weapon is a
crafted weapon so i need to keep
grinding out that level and it's just
like when am i going to get to use the
weapons i want i want to get inside
you feel like your waste you're wasting
activities or you're wasting kills if
you're using something that is not
contributing forward good kills without
much right
yeah you're kidding me yeah
in legend like i just threw that out the
window i'm like i don't i can't be using
whatever d like i actually have to have
a loadout for legends so yes i guess
maybe for like this this does give a
reason for lower level activities to be
you know get something out of them like
i could just run strikes for the sake of
getting through all my deep set weapons
or leveling stuff whereas before running
strikes literally had no purpose so
maybe there's some benefit there in that
sense but i i do see what you're saying
and like i do feel that too where it's
like i'm always just using kind of this
random hodgepodge of weapons unless i'm
like in a really difficult activity
sidearm rifle it's a little strange
yeah a sidearm pulsar rifle grenade
launcher all with terrible perks that's
my loadout right now okay cool
not using any special weapon the good
news is to extract deep sight it's like
two activities essentially and then
you're done yeah but
yeah yeah i was gonna add i i know what
mine's this and we
my gripe we called it
when we found out
how master working was going to change
yeah
and
bro i am very upset
with help with helmet armor right now
because it's like
oh i i sit there and i've got a stasis
build going
and i want to create orbs for my uh
agent scepter
and it costs three so now i gotta decide
okay am i gonna have scavenger on the
other side because you want scavenger
then you got other perks that's
associated and you literally cannot fit
all of that in those two boxes
and i hate not being able to choose it
that pigeonholed in there and then the
cost it correct me if i'm wrong doesn't
it vary based on um somebody told me i
don't know if i is correct but someone
told me it varies based on the subclass
that you choose or whatever that but if
not even if it doesn't mean our story
and void aren't going to cost any
different
okay
there but there's certain things that
are like different yeah there can be
like kinetic there can be harmonic that
matches with your subclass there are
different styles as opposed to just like
void or something i haven't really dug
as much into those because
yeah i was like it's yeah i knew it was
going to be worse it does work
it's like
orbs i had to switch to elemental oh wow
that's because i think it was too
annoying
to manage it yeah and i think that was
kind of their goal too so yeah i think
the go yeah the goal was to get us off
you know double scavenger double finders
or whatever using to protectively got
nerfed into the ground yeah i took that
off immediately that was my build going
in for the campaign and then i'm like oh
well this is pointless so yeah so like
i'm just curious because i haven't even
really run it as much like how much of a
difference is it how insignificant like
what what's the major change of
protective like that yeah down to ten
percent it's down to ten percent it was
what 50 once you hit that low level it
was a bit it was really it was at least
40. it was 40 yeah it was large and it's
down to 10 and then they swapped in what
is it font of
tenacity it might be the one that gives
you the introduction if you pick up a
certain well
yeah
then you get that damage reduction for a
certain time but it's only at that
moment it's not when you need it in that
clutch hey i'm about to die
when you need it the most it's like on
demand if you want to be aggressive
which in theory if you're trying to you
know push onto these hive guardians i
can see that having some
kind of benefit if you gotta go crush a
ghost type thing um but on the other
side
yeah it is it is frustrating to see so
much up potential in that helmet slot
and know that you can't even really
scratch the all the surface it's like i
can be kind of a jack of some trades
absolute master of zero i feel like i'm
shooting myself in the toe i'm messing
with any it's yeah it's weird and where
my anger really hit its peak with that
is that some of the artifact bots also
go in that slot because there was some
from like you know making more using uh
uh melee and then you you can generate
uh more what you call more power like it
was it became this cycle of like there's
literally four to five useful productive
things in two slots and i hate that i am
so limited now like that part really got
me mad i think it's the foundry mods the
new foundry mods for the artifacts
that's the ones that extend the timers
on your boundary perks are in the helmet
slot too so
yeah i want i hadn't actually paid
attention to where those go but yeah i
was like um honestly most of what you
guys have said is kind of touching i've
i'm hitting that point in weapon
crafting um i think i'm on the exact
same you said the tarnation i need to
craft those two and i just hadn't quite
looked into where it is so we're almost
at the same point but i've seen people
like say the cap of the weapon crafting
the legendary alloys not the exotic one
but it's only like 260 or something
there's 250 250 or something you're like
so i get 12 every so often okay i've
been breaking some down working on them
but then is we don't have extra vault
space so then is there the point i'm
gonna have
red weapons
that are completed but not actually
pulled the resource out of just
stockpiling my vault so i have that
stuff on demand if i need it i've
wondered that too yeah i'm like i think
it depends i don't know what the neutral
element cap is that's the size it seems
like so that's going to be big right so
like i've even if i'm not getting the
plus 12 anymore i've still been
extracting just to get the 200 neutral
because
i really need a lot of that but i can
see a point where you you're just going
to get people stockpiling completed deep
sites in the vault and like lord knows
we do not have room for that so
and the other issue is when you look at
the enhanced perks
you want to get to these enhanced perks
eventually and you guys have described
the issue i'm sitting there like okay i
gotta use trash weapon for 20 levels or
40 activities or whatever this thing's
gonna be who knows how long that thing's
gonna take to unlock
so you're gonna use junk is it worth
spending extra currency in the in like
on level eight to get some of the perks
yeah no it is i think it is true i never
do it yeah no i i absolutely think it is
it depends on the perks like yeah but if
you get the non-enhanced version of
whatever enhanced persian you're looking
for just get it like it's it's
worth nothing literally it's 300
currency it is one and a half deep site
weapons which is not a big deal and it
will make this like much
more you know bearable like when i put
when i put impulse amplifier on my
glaive
uh for instance like i want advanced you
know impulse but it that alone totally
changed the whole concept of the glaive
to me and like that was the best 300
neutral element i've ever spent but
that's
just like a like really fast projectile
it's just beast it's so fast
it's it feels like how i can't imagine
using a glaive projectile without it now
like that is
um how much of a difference it is so
like that was one example and then i put
frenzy in the other slot and like that
you know that was 600 neutral elements
so that's three deep sight weapons and
like i'm almost level 20 now so i i can
get all the unlocked perks i want once i
get more alloys but i i don't regret
spending that to get to this point
because of how much it made using that
weapon in the interim a lot better
because like i had like unrelenting and
like the shield tilting and mills
perking like those those don't do
anything that was was not good so i'm
waiting for a level 30 on everything and
i'm cool this is 30 years
i thought it was 20. it's 20. i thought
20 is the last three months money gets
you the extra stat boost 20 is where you
cap out a weapon that's like master
working i think is getting it to 20.
level 30 at
our new friend which we'll talk about
later is 30
does that give you like um the ornament
the little gambit thing yeah that's what
i'm thinking about 30 give 30 gives you
the ornament and the ornament has
special effects i need to look this up
because i was like i don't have it i
thought you had to go into the game
i thought you had to go into gambit to
actually earn it it's not something you
just unlocked but you you can't apply it
to a campaign apply it until you get 10
more levels until you're yeah until
you're maxed it whatever okay well okay
fully outside of cosmetics
is 20.
so
uh yeah i mean that's kind of the thing
it's like crafting is exciting because i
know there's a path if i get a pulse
rifle the soros pulse rifle stasis one
feeling pretty good i'm like i know
there's a path where i eventually can
get
a good roll as opposed to having bad rng
for the next year
which for me does have a lot of
potential but then on the other side as
you said
it is a rather tedious process to get
there i did miss one thing as well hot
take and this kind of covers basically
the other thing that you guys may have
touched on uh the liz with a five dollar
super chat crucible and gambit will have
minimal changes over the next two years
pve has higher skilling for elite
content higher ceiling for elite content
bungie will lead to that and honestly i
think that's what this is
probably showing too it's like i know we
got like a gambit rework
i haven't touched gambit for those of
you guys that have touched gambit
is it
how does it feel
it's meant for the gambit expert travis
continue
okay i mean i play
enough to get the pinnacle on two
characters so that's six games
um
so okay
the good things i like what they did
with the primeval phase there is less
just like insta bursting of the primeval
uh now that you actually have to go it's
a gambit prime you have to go around to
the envoy locations
and kill them and it slows it down it
gives a little more chance for counter
play
there is less invasion i'd say overall
but when there is invasion now everyone
is getting heavy ammo at the end of
every section that's cleared yeah so the
invader always has heavy whenever they
need it
some good changes or minor like your
dead teammates dropping half their moats
is nice
that's pretty good
uh
and
it's interesting with so with void 3.0
and how how everything is chained uh
volatile explosions everywhere like yeah
sides are cleared almost by the time you
can even like start
getting over it like that because
everyone is running void 3.0 and
everyone has on like explosive whatever
the frame
so those are just getting cleared out
altogether but it's just you know
they're good rules changes but like are
they enough to be like yeah i really
want to grind gambit now like probably
not
what gambit really needs is
something like a significant shake up
like the return of the prime rolls like
they said a million years ago they're
going to make those mods it never
happens uh they still we are still
negative two maps into gambit now they
took two of the six maps away so we need
those back to start with uh and we need
more gambit maps because like you can't
have a core
pillar mode with four maps like it just
yeah it gives stall and like they change
they change some of the enemy spawns and
like i was like surprised that scribes
are back now that was an unpleasant uh
thing to discover
so
it makes it a little less samey because
there's more enemy bio biomes but
it's
it's still gambit it just feels a little
bit more like prime now i i would say
and
the primeval being summoned first is not
like a death sentence freelance is good
because there's not more stacks
uh highly coordinated to just burst it
down instantly um but with like with
everything else to do in the witch queen
like who's gonna be playing gambit
anytime seriously and the reason you
know i'll play it in a couple months
from now once i'm fully out of stuff to
do so i can earn the little drink it but
yep yeah other than that yeah
yeah i gotta agree with paul i think
it's it's just not enough right like
clearly this is kind of them just
putting dipping their toe into
uh trying to address the gambit issue
but it really isn't enough and and
they've kind of been doing the same very
similar treatment to crucible for a lot
longer
um
in terms of the hot take
that they will have uh minimal changes
over the next two years i i think yeah
probably but uh i don't think that's
good and i i disagree with the the
saying that there's a higher ceiling for
elite content if i'm even understanding
what that is supposed to mean correctly
but um plenty of games use pvp and have
a very high content for
uh or very high ceiling for elite
content and in fact some games are only
pvp and do very very well with that i
mean fortnite and uh apex legends and
all those live service games do very
well with it i think the
potential with with those modes is
simply just far less realized than pve
people think of destiny as a pve first
game
mostly because that's what it's been
most successful at doing that doesn't
mean that that should be how it is
that's you know that's that's uh
thinking of it completely backwards so
uh thank you for the super chat it only
costs 4.99 to be wrong i guess
that's what i have to say
really encouraging those these donations
yeah appreciate you appreciate that yeah
shout out to the super chats you guys
are the rock stars travis on the other
hand we gotta talk no i'm just kidding
that money didn't go to me that's all i
gotta say
he's splitting up the five yo i do gotta
get at the bill one thing um console at
least for me
xbox i don't know what happened with hdr
but it looks washed out and many people
are complaining there is a major
hdr dull color look now some of my
friends because i'm playing on the oled
cx
and i remember how vibrant this game
would look like it's beautiful and i'm
like yo why it look washed out now some
of my friends who are not on oled
they're like yo it looks better it looks
great so there's clearly some hdr
tinkering and i'm looking at the trouble
and they talk about it it's it's a
bullet point so i'm like yes because i
knew i wasn't bucking i was like that
game is a beautiful game for ksg on oled
so yeah they weren't looks like they
were working on it working on the kings
and i know we'll get into the trial but
i had to mention that for oleg owners it
does not look pretty right now yeah i
will say for me on pc2 i've
the
the long term playing causing are you on
pc paul
i've i've done both okay the pc menu
stutter and lag is really rough yeah i
never experienced that like if console
i've noticed a little slow down as well
but on pc it's like
like hard glitching every time you kind
of like go into
uh your inventory which is apparently
there's issues where you can roll back
your nvidia drivers and help some of the
issues with that because the recent ones
may have messed it up but even for me
i'll be going on a sparrow and i'll jump
on and move and i don't know if
something doesn't quite catch up but the
whole screen is like off fuzzy
while i'm driving on a spare then if i
slow down it kind of like settles for a
sec and then gets then i can go fast
again too
but yeah the slow downs i got to a point
and then people have said like the
longer you play if things are really
starting to chug close down the game
buda back up you kind of like it so i
don't know if it's like a memory leak
but that i will say is like when you
said like the bugginess on pc
there have been i haven't messed with
hdr because i've been streaming can't do
both at the same time right right um so
i'll have to mess with that a little bit
or maybe i'll be curious to see but
at least for
graphics drivers and stutters and memory
leaks and stuff like that that is kind
of
a little annoying to a point where
you're like kind of want to enjoy this
one all of a sudden i'm looking at my
screen i'm like feels like my mind just
like shifted half a degree i'm like hold
on so it's just this weird looking
screen for a second and that's the weird
one i've seen and i don't even know if
it comes through on stream but it's just
this weird blur when i jump on a sparrow
quick and go
and that combined with like the mini and
yeah i want to just let me look at this
thing in my menu and everything's just
taking longer and longer to load that's
that's been definitely
they definitely got some growing pains
on initially want to launch the small
glitches i know it's console
specifically you know loading up going
between weapons waiting to see for the
perks to cut to pop up to see that
there's that little bit of a truck there
so they work good to go on planes for
sure they definitely have some issues
there
yeah um
so season of the risen since we did talk
about a lot of witch queen and kind of
the big content drop we did also get a
new season
um
not too much with relates to
spoilery so you can kind of go into what
you want to
talk about there kind of the cinematic
what we're doing a little bit and
anything that you guys have experienced
so far the new battlegrounds
psiops battlegrounds
um there's only one so far
yeah i do once we don't have the roadmap
but i i maybe it'll be one next week i'm
not sure there'll be three one for each
of the uh subclasses
yeah yeah yeah that would make sense i
mean i'm happy to see battlegrounds back
i battlegrounds were my favorite
seasonal activity of last year too they
do really great things with enemy
density um this continues that uh but
with hive
this is
a little weird with the like whole
transport you know the mindscape and you
fight staffing clones and like then
there's tons and tons of enemies but
it's it's certainly fun um i i thought
it was funny in the beginning cut scene
where kyle's like
hey you killed all my dudes in the
opening mission i'm like those were your
dudes like what yeah
that's what i was saying i was i was
playing with destin i was like why are
we killing these cabal aren't these
kittens
and he was like he was like we have an
alliance with kyle travis shut up and
then afterward like right after that we
went and played that mission and she was
like you killed my friends and destiny's
like i guess you were right
but
yeah yeah that was confusing but um the
armor sets are really sick even the base
armor sets are so good i already tried
the titan one um
i i haven't gotten a ton of the weapons
yet but so far they seem good i it's
it's a little hard to tell i'm still not
even like fully
um
familiar with every new perk and stuff
uh the the ability of
getting resilience and damage resistance
on kill that's a good foundation that's
my joint yeah that's very good
so that that's kind of a demonstration
of what we're gonna see
every season is gonna have one of these
presumably for these seasonal weapons
yeah and uh i maintain they're gonna
bring back black armory weapons um and
put a foundry perk on that i'm 100 sure
about that i don't know when but
uh but there's not a whole lot really to
to go into the season yet because it
kind of hards ending after the first um
battlegrounds quest and you're just sort
of
you know you can grind levels and things
but there's it's time gated like mostly
it's getting skipped
yeah yeah same thing i i played it and
i'll play one of them
pretty cool you know nothing like
mind-blowing but i i did like the
weapons i did i like i got that um what
was it the recurrent impact the machine
gun had that resilience trait i love it
you know and i i think it's a 900 i
believe yeah
it feels good i got headstone on it and
perpetual motion
i'm rocking bro so i did a stasis build
with that um the armor says look good
but uh yeah like it's the first thing i
went when i went to the wood table i'm
like all right let me see what i got to
do to unlock it's like week two you'll
be able to do this and i'm like oh here
we go
you know we're gonna extend it
yeah i think it's like five weeks though
not like the full eight or whatever it
seems short because there's only
it seems like a shorter set of unlocks
or things and maybe it's just because
obviously more goes into which queen but
it's weird to only have i don't know if
it's just a few weeks of story or things
shift in another direction
mm-hmm but yeah we're in step seven of
28 after week one so yeah
and then presumably you know
no you're right
the consolidation of the umbral engrams
within the helm i thought was
interesting like now you know before i'm
so used to going to all the different
and or having the past active seasons
you know still listed so that's gone and
now you have to page over
and then you can do what is it the uh
dreaming city arsenal
there's another one for the armor and
then there's one that requires the
special currency which is the third
what's the third one name paul you know
what that third one forgot that name of
that word it's whatever the see it's
like a little little cape i don't
everyone's called yeah it's it's the one
to make seasonal weapons in our right
but it's weird because there's that
umbrella section but then you go to
rahul
and rahul is always like hey i can
decrypt your umbral engrams into nothing
like
and every time you go to rahul that
comes up and i had i didn't realize that
you could exit out of that engram screen
and then there's a whole bunch of other
stuff like that's how i figured out you
could buy
a send an alloy from him because
obviously i have a bunch of umbrella
engrams at any time so that's the first
thing that comes up so i don't really
understand
why they're letting him decrypt
umbrella
because he can't complain
it's because people were complaining
that you oh you had to go to two
separate locations yeah yeah you have to
go to school and i was actually one of
those people i agree with at night but
you can't i think it's them
yeah you can't focus them which sort of
defeats the entire purpose but i will
say something
sometimes you just need to dump them out
of your inventory yeah yeah
i mean so certainly yeah later in the
season you're going to be happy that
you're happy that you did because you're
just going to want to get rid of that
stuff once you have probably true yes
yeah i want to point out one thing what
you guys feel about this shift from
when you when you dismantle blues and
now uh gutsmith gets reputation
reputation
how you guys feel about that
it's better it's bad because blue still
exists but yeah i'm i was like i'm
swimming
and then dumping them for whatever like
it's good i think
that it's a passive level up system like
i'm level six or seven already just not
really even paying attention to it uh
and that that's i think gonna be a way
to earn a guaranteed alloy every 16
levels but that's a pretty decent amount
of dismantling to get to that point
um i i don't know i mean it's better but
i i still maintain we need auto
dismantle blue like once i hit 1500 it
should be
no more blues even like
then you for sure never need another one
because everything's 50 is when they
should turn it off yeah and then shout
out
at some
to elaborate my opinion there will be
more dev time and effort geared for
better and harder pve content than pvp
not sliding pvp pvp elite players we've
been told major pvp updates with a nun
so
yeah see you guys uh you guys uh
criticized me for being hard on the
commenter but look i just tripled your
money
welcome
buddy that's the uh it's playing against
the house right there apparently they
win sometimes
in there man shout out to the legend
listen to the guy in the tucks i think
is the takeaway from us so you're the
dealer tonight
more like the waiter but that's okay
okay um
no uh i thank you for for your comment
um i i i understand and i agree that
that will probably happen uh pve will
will always be their their bread and
butter i think especially with them
making a different game that is probably
going to mostly be pvp it sounds like
just based on what we know about it i
think
pvp and gambit will probably always take
a backseat i don't think that that's
wrong necessarily but as a aspirational
destiny is the chosen one type of person
i would like it to one day be the
ultimate package of pvp
pve and gambit and just be able to do
all these things very successfully and
have separate teams to support these on
a more regular basis at the scale that
they do with their pve world i would
love that uh maybe i'm dreaming they
just got acquired by a big company
though so who knows
maybe in a couple years when this 10
year saga finishes up you'll finally get
a little pvp to let it live
has to die so i can get my dedicated pvp
team
you know what the dredging's gonna have
to follow that sword for me actually
yeah sinister what up drifter's like uh
what happened and shax is like keep
drift keep drifter just
yeah
i'm okay with no more gambit honestly
yeah
no doubt
ah void 3.0 very good
campaign really enjoyed everything
season the risen seems like it has a
very cool potential i'm enjoying it was
like here here it was almost like the
perfect time when you go through the
story there's this like kind of little
level gap i'm like oh there's probably
some stuff i should go do and then you
literally go check out that thing do
that and kind of come back and you're
good like that's the they kind of made
that just a perfect little step to go
talk but when you got the the few
cinematics that we've had this time
around
um
well i'll save the big one for spoilers
but even the one with kyle
yes
her detail
man that is i think her model is
probably one that whoever put that thing
together then rendered that video out
that is probably almost the most
detailed i think anything that we've
seen rendered for a character probably
in the cinematics her detail her little
armor chinks and everything are
absolutely ridiculous so so my problem
is i just came from about 30 hours of
horizon forbidden okay fine
[Music]
it's hard like you know destiny's always
it's a beautiful game in many ways but
like it's still it's there's still at
this break point between cut scenes and
then game dialogue and so it's like when
you have icora talking like with the
mission like only moving her mouth
essentially yeah
and like comparing it to her like again
it's apples and oranges but like i hope
we get to a place someday where like
destiny has that level of detail and
still plays like destiny it might be the
next console generation for all you know
like are you implying a three on the
number
we apply a new engine
i think we're going to be at destiny 2
for
the rest of this console generation
because we have two more expansions
and they've said that they're going to
do more destiny 2 stuff after that
that's the whole console generation so
yes i think destiny 3 will arrive at
some point and it'll be
um
probably right around ps6 and you know
whatever
whatever everything's in the cloud and
there's no more consoles anymore i was
going to say whatever xbox names their
next console because they always gotta
do something different
um no it's like that's series x no see
it's not series now it's gotta be a new
name everything's gonna happen so that's
why they called it siri so keep using it
because that's what iphone does so now
you're gonna be the xbox neptune or
something like they just you know
they'll just do something completely and
then the upgrade is uranus it'll be it's
s2 and x2 s3 and x3 just like i well
they're going to do more series before
that i think another like a series a or
something but ps5 um
plus before so okay so before we get
into spoilers or whatever can i can i
take a brief aside to yes uh evangelize
for our lord and savior the glaive oh
yes this is the time guys dj listen up
everybody get in front of the
congregation i'm probably gonna put this
all into an article tomorrow but
uh the legendary campaign really
reinforced
my love for the versatility of the
glaive i've i've seen it getting kind of
a lot of crap someone even said it was
impossible to beat legends using a the
bass glaive and i'm like i literally
just did it but
okay so great though
i i only upgraded it in the last two
missions out of eight like i i was
rocking the stupid tilting windmills
perk forever so a few things are
required to make you a glaive convert
and the first thing i mentioned earlier
is impulse amplifier this thing
it always feels a little clunky to shoot
the glaive thing like it's it's a
projectile it doesn't have like the best
tracking or anything but putting impulse
amplifier on it just it's it's almost
instant it makes it a rocket and like
impulse amplifier has always been an
interesting perk on like grenade
launchers and rocket launchers it's kind
of curious on bows i can kind of notice
it but it's like maybe less so glaives
it's like the defining perk for glaze i
think and on top of that it adds a bunch
of reload speed
uh as well just in case you need more of
that too and then i paired that with
frenzy for damage and handling nice and
more reload speed and so that's like
your baseline good glaive uh
i don't think people have really looked
at the full suite of artifact mods this
season
the yeah future of glaze we'll see but
there is a mod that is
suppressing glaive
where every glaive shot will suppress an
enemy
and
that's insane like it's it's not just
suppression is not just for
you know hive guardians and stuff
although it does work beautifully on
them it's it blinds any enemy which just
for a long time at least five seconds
there are other perks that extends the
duration of suppression and there is
another perk that makes it's called
suppressive darkness yeah that makes
suppressed enemies uh be weakened and
there is another perk
uh that is uh no it's not a perk it's a
fragment for ford 3.0 where every time
you suppress an enemy you uh gain
mobility and auto reload yes
so you combine all of those things
together and you put that on one weapon
plus unstoppable glaive if you want to
uh
have champions too plus oh they
appreciate they they preaching for you
right now they appreciate all hail the
gladiator glaive they ended up david
yeah david james
the glaive for the two dollar super chat
crystal can afford another tux yeah i
think i gotta go get it i gotta dress
nicer next time uh christopher sharp
with the hundred dollar super chat all
hail the glaive geez
[ __ ] then jesus yeah paul
that is righteous and then okay so
the fight then the final piece is the
intrinsic foundry perk of i i guess it's
just witch queen weapons or throne world
weapons which is the psycho
psycho something where it reduces damage
so
stabbing people with the glaive costs no
ammo first of all and you can like two
or three shot
most enemies uh it's not like your boss
dps weapon but it can do that uh
stabbing people will activate
suppression
so it'll blind them it will also
uh so it will weaken them and it will
also reduce their damage because of that
front that psycho trait so if they're
not suppressed if you don't have
suppression on they're still doing less
damage output and so what i found is
that it counters like boss stop in a lot
of ways where
you won't even a boss may not even break
your shield if you're hacking at someone
with a glaive and you have that active
uh
and
combine all these things together and
this is how the glaive carried me
through the entire entire legend
way way more than i ever thought
possible and i didn't even mention the
shield i don't really use the shield
like it's it's there and i know some
people are like protecting their
teammates i genuinely just barely ever
even used it because the defensive
capabilities of suppressing an enemy and
lowering their damage output alone were
enough to make it a good uh
offensive defensive weapon so
really really really recommend
you put those uh artifact mods on once
you get there and put impulse amplifier
on it you will like glaze i can almost
promise you did i make a counter
argument can i debate yeah
you can't oh here we go no church
churches searches are upset and let's
make a counter argument oh yeah
i am the congregation can now leave
i'm pretty aggressively against the
glaive
sorry i just heard christopher sharp
gave me one hundred dollars i am for the
growing
[Laughter]
tombstone will read check with mr sharp
no i i also like the glaive i've been
using it uh i've been using it pretty
pretty regularly through yeah and so no
i do think it'll probably be useless in
pvp but timeline oh i heard somebody on
twitter literally is like the glam is
great no i watch somebody on twitter
just be like it's probably not the
greatest but it's hilarious trying to
watch two people stab each other because
it's like the animation head
registration is terrible yeah
so that's not gonna be good
now paul you're on fire because it's
like literally i one of the things with
a new season with me i always get
excited as i go through that artifact
you know you you go right over to the
last two callers okay what are they
trying to get me to play and i looked at
that suppression i was like yo then you
got glaive uh scavenger you got it's
literally built for it i mean obviously
there's some other cool ones i believe
there's like a um suppressive one in
there there's a couple other cool ones
in here but it's it's it's really
influencing you to utilize this weapon
and yeah i'm with you man i got to use
it a little bit more but i i was just
going for this season
it's going to be strong yeah
it's too good with suppression right now
yeah in typical bungee fashion like they
generally try to nudge you and encourage
you towards the new you know weapon or
the new thing that mechanic that they've
introduced but yeah it's you have to at
least try and use it in the
effectiveness it's it's off the chain
yeah um also a just a quick second
recommendation
absolutely start experimenting with
exotic primaries again like i i know
that was not the most heralded change
yeah graviton really i use outbreak for
the entire legend run yeah like it just
outbreaks players red bars the new
osseos trigger
the mouse is everything like it's a 40
buff across the board and like
almost all of the like
pretty okay weapons from before are now
just insane so i would
experiment with those for sure talk
about that
for a second have you guys used that
thing
yes my boy has been trying to use the
catalyst but yes it is even without it
it's crazy it was like this is if you
have the what is it is it only part of
the deluxe edition though is that
correct right now okay so have to have
the deluxe have to have the season pass
which basically all comes together
so if you don't have it i am sorry
that's gonna be a thing um but i will
tell you
would you just start shooting and then
just all the ads in a small cert they
just melt they just kind of wither away
and it you can just unload you can look
at a boss with a machine gun it doesn't
matter what you're looking at with that
thing two clips
will kill most every boss would probably
face groups of ads die like i shot like
three bullets because i was actually
trying to get precision kills
with osteostream so i'm like one bullet
okay that's a head shot one bullet head
shot one more bullet everybody died like
when you got the kill everything dies
near it it
that thing for ad clearing probably in
the raid especially is going to be
ludicrous so having somebody with that
on alone is going to be
massively beneficial i think good
transition i had a guy that like shot my
boy gaming attic lord attic in a
building um big raid questions so like
what are we thinking what do we what are
we go first of all what are you thinking
raid minimum and then what are you going
in there with i mean we don't know the
rate minimum yet we still don't it's not
in the twelve no it's they don't put it
in the swatch i gotta assume it'll be
15.50 then if they haven't said it i
would guess it's probably 15 20 because
it's not going to matter it's just
contest yeah i i think this is contest
it won't really like 15 20 15 30.
yeah yeah
13.50 so blues who just turned on the
game can go in
oh man that would be i would
here's your first exp you take six
people who have never played destiny and
plop them into a raid and just say if
you can finish this you each get a
lamborghini but you have 24 hours go
so
i was like that's mr beast go ahead you
can take that one go find my guess is um
that the raid we know the rate is taking
this is not a spoiler but we know the
rate is taking place inside the pyramid
that is inside saboteum's throne world
which is not an actual pyramid but
rather a mental representation of
sabbathun's time with the the witness
and uh
we i my guess is that the raid is going
to have at least some involvement in the
final trailer you see in the campaign
going with it without it without going
to spoilers i think should we go into
spoilers now i feel like i was going to
say it later
we're going to talk about the raid and
potential boss and yeah yeah so at this
point uh we are about an hour and 20
minutes in so we're going to open up to
spoilers we can go through basically all
the story beats we can go through the
campaign missions breaking breaking news
all right
uh raid date march 5th 10 a.m p.m
pacific standing time raid power for
contest mode 15 30. more details next
week beautiful i'm already there where
is 15 30 addict
where'd that happen
on the official bungie twitter account
beautiful
like oops i forgot to put this in the
[ __ ] yeah i'm like
how do you not there it is yeah so i'm
already geared up 15 30. there we go we
were right yeah i was like my job's done
that's easy
even if you're doing the campaign on
normal even you'll be 15 30 by then
honestly
yeah without without even trying um
so
that's cool
yeah spoilers at this point everything
that we're going to open up at this
point is everything that we've pretty
much all experienced i know cog finished
the campaign so i was glad to see you
got that one so we're going to go
through all campaign story beats
speculation about raid all of that stuff
is going to be on the table now so
if you haven't enjoyed the campaign yet
by the way both baloney that's big lies
nonsense you haven't played it with like
an arm tied behind your back on your
other characters maybe but that's the
first build yeah what is pvp
if you if you want to save this part of
the podcast or you want to just check
out now and maybe kind of come back
after other things now is the time to
follow all these amazing people ty guy
travis lord cognito iron lords paul
iron lords podcast almost just combined
you two together uh paul tassie on
twitter uh forbes articles and of course
on his exploding youtube channel um all
of those things go follow subscribe like
and donate to all of these wonderful
people and you can look at the forbes
articles without that without the ads
now
and the subscription so that was a huge
victory for this there's still ads just
notepad yeah ads are everywhere i'm
sorry ads are everywhere
you just don't have to pay for it and
next time we hear from
paul tassie because he's a friend of the
show and comes by every so often um
his house may be a little fuller by the
time that comes around so before we get
into spoilers i did want to touch on
that how far are you away
uh almost exactly a month from the due
date okay nice and
yeah
we're family planning spoilers
sorry we didn't uh make that make that
clear but
yeah so just just a month now when we're
buying all the things and
painting the nursery and all that stuff
so yeah good times
are you actually facing the nursery just
unsettled with what's going on she knows
something's happening but
that is one of those things about like
dogs we'll pack up for vacation have
dogs have our bags by the door
like the night before and
they you can just tell there's something
going on but i'm sure are you actually
painting the nursery
uh
someone is painting the nursery who i am
paying to paint the nursery there you go
well you know what paul i have to say
this about you as a father
okay
having a child is sort of like the
ultimate live service game
and who better equipped
to handle that task than the than the
games as a service master himself paul
tassie yeah well thank you
faith in me
got to get them up so so many fun
metaphors that we'll be having on
twitter like how's his light level he's
like he's seven it's insane
he's not ready he's definitely not ready
definitely
okay on that note we are going to go
into spoiler territory at this point um
so if you are looking to duck out now we
definitely appreciate all the viewers
have been here so far if you're ready
for the spoilers then this is that time
uh where do you guys want to start do
you guys want to just work our way kind
of through the story that we got it they
did it guys this is the thing i've been
most excited to talk about which it
told a good story in destiny
i didn't know it was possible i this is
the first time in a livestream my
estimation because for all the things
the taken king was
it was a great it did it did a lot for
destiny as a sandbox and as a game but
it didn't do a lot for destiny as a
story in my opinion it just sort of like
gave you a baddie that was more
intimidating than the no villain that
existed in destiny manila and let you
kill him but this one was like it had
twists it had us turning the tables on
him and on the the witch queen and
learning the the truth about what's
going on uh it had cut scenes and
references to you know
fundaments and
it was just so
good i i will say the only thing i'm
upset about is they killed
we talked about this i thought about you
bro don't
watch i was very disappointed granted
the ghost got away
do you think she's dead no we know she's
there
i don't know
what she is dead but like they left it
open so she could be resurrected
obviously
so i talked to somebody about about this
i had a very similar conversation and my
my counter argument to that is yes but
that is true of everyone in destiny
everyone that we've killed could come
back all of them like there's not like
there's not even one
it's you could always write
resurrections back somehow if you if you
really want to i think they did this
so the campaign would have a conclusive
ending that feels like you accomplished
something because if you shot her and
she just teleported away again yeah
laughing that would not have been a
satisfying ending so i think having her
at least temporarily dead was was the
right call but i i do not think this is
going to be an aramis situation where
it's like maybe ernest will come back
and then she's frozen forever and
nothing ever happens yeah
no you've invested too much into sabbath
and like yeah
17 starts talking to you
in the post missions
all these voicemails before my death
like yeah yeah no i agree i agree i i
think it's
it's purposely done they wanted to they
they they told the line of wanting to
give a satisfying campaign and into
their credit travel i give even though
we laugh about the hayah ooga booga
moments where we just go in there slap
and that's it to their credit
they built her up as far i'm just
talking about from the fighting
standpoint yeah the the sheer amount of
encounter i'm gonna tell you one thing i
got goosebumps
when you go up that staircase
and that
the the guard
bro it was some dark souls i a sauron
vibe going up in there and i'm like okay
and then when i beat that
oh i'm all right that was intense you
know we running around hiding in a
little corner you know try to dps her
down then the light got high hive
guardians come out and then you go to
the next sequence and that was the
witches but to the story i really where
it really resonated with me
was
how
they really told the story of the hive
and the lie the lie really hit me
because all this time because you know
they had that internal battle especially
zavala he's like yo
this is bs like everything he was led to
believe he's now questioning like yo we
you know what why would the traveler do
this and i kind of like carl's like i
don't even care why we have to protect
humanity at this point you know kind of
thing but i just thought it was
interesting that
the hive got a little bit of a
redemption arc slightly that they were
tricked they could yeah but the thing is
like so this is my pr the problem that i
do have with them killing uh with them
essentially killing her off right is
that is that
they
they sort of set up the redemption arc
and there were a lot of things leading
toward it and including sabathun
seemingly not really having a ton of
evil intention it almost seemed like she
was trying to help us or be on our side
had a relationship with the traveler all
that stuff and
it then at the end you get that
monologue from your ghost where he's
like look you guys killed everyone like
i'll never forget all the stuff that you
guys did like you're irredeemable and
then you sort of just go with that and i
i kind of thought like
to me as of all as being short-sighted
like yeah the the traveler chose the
hive because he believes i think that
the traveler's point of view is that the
hive can be redeemed and that people can
be worthy even if you know all the evil
and that they were betrayed themselves
and that they they had a shot at
redemption so to me it was like a story
of redemption where we were like we sort
of like overrode it with our own actions
and at the last moment we're like no
actually we're not gonna let that happen
we're just gonna kill you so maybe
they'll change that down the road but i
i was a little disappointed
at that choice to just be like nah you
know what you're still evil you're done
to paul's credit because i watch your
video paul in reference to um your
initial reaction after it isn't there
law going on after that
post you know when i think it's still
the exotic quest or whatever that you
find out that she somehow protected the
travel traveler earlier right so again
the choice was made she she was given
the light and i still think that
redemption arc is there they i think
they're clearly bringing her back but
for the sake of a satisfying campaign
we're going to just do this for right
now and the ghost is going to go away
but i'm curious that ian and travis
and paul on your thoughts on that whole
part the lie
clearly we got to talk about the witness
because that's a whole other thing yeah
god i'm so excited about the witness we
got to talk about the winner but i i
want
and paul as far as the the hive and
where they sit with you now like how
does that feel now
uh so i had some inklings of this kind
of going into the campaign because
in the uh
the lore for the collector's edition
they're talking about how the ghosts
feel bad for the hive and they think
they've been taken advantage of by the
darkness i didn't realize that would
lead to the big reveal of the lie um but
that is
at first i was very satisfied to
learn that my theory beforehand that the
hive ghosts had chosen to work with the
hive that they weren't like enslaved
or something and you're like wait so if
they
chose this then like what does that mean
about the traveler and then so like
you're going and going and like i had my
suspicions i at least brought up the
possibility before launch that the
traveler had given sabbath dune delight
willingly because
i didn't really buy that
with how good bungie storytelling has
been recently i didn't buy it was going
to be like ah sabathune studied void
exactly yeah like figured out how to
siphon it from there and like they had
me fooled though with the security thing
they had me fooled in the beginning
mission i i was fooled that like she
figured out some way and i was gonna
roll my eyes and then when they didn't
do that i was so relieved continue paul
i mean she she kind of did like i think
she did glean a lot of stuff from her
time as osiris in terms of
what what makes guardians worthy of the
light when like other races maybe aren't
or in the same way so i i think that was
partially true and that she learned from
ecora and the vanguard and things like
that but it wasn't like she found like
ah this is the secret formula to light
like that would have been really lame
and i'm glad they didn't do that so like
i i was thrilled with the cutscene um on
the cliff that was oh the witness was
great for other reasons but like this
the cut scene on the cliff where it was
a gamble for her she didn't know she
didn't work and she was like kind of
putting it all on the line and so this
creates a really interesting situation
where
there were two forces that are both kind
of being selfish for their own reasons
so so everything got the light but in
like in service of that she protected
the traveler in theory by transporting
the traveler to her throne world where
presumably the darkness couldn't reach
it i had my doubts that that's true
considering all the yeah
there's a pyramid in there but yeah yeah
um though
right so
she got the light and you know got rid
of her worm and and stuff and the
trailer got protection whereas we
were scared we're gonna lose our light
so our plan is even if sabithune is
technically protecting the traveler
we're we're simply doing what i cora
said we're like it doesn't matter like
if we let her take that we're going to
be super vulnerable to literally
everything and we're going to go extinct
so we are choosing ourselves
over the traveler and like i will the
traveler punish us for that or something
i don't know
how the travelers do it yeah
maybe maybe and i mean we're we're
coming to you know the end of this light
and dark saga in two years so
something like that is gonna have to
happen like the traveler is probably not
gonna be around forever right i thought
this was a really interesting kind of
moral quandary set up between guardians
and sabathune and the traveler and then
kind of the x factor is
the darkness itself and the witness and
what that what it actually wants and
things like that but
seventh i think is is the best
characterized
character in in all of destiny we've
been the past year like laura before
that and then now what we saw realized
with her storyline this was just such a
non-traditional thing like aramis even
even as recently you know fiona had an
okay story but it was like aramis made a
deal with the darkness to get power and
like she's mad at the traveler because
the traveler abandoned the election yeah
it's fine it's a good story but it's
pretty straightforward whereas this was
like all over the place both in terms of
like figuring out mysteries within 17
story and then learning just huge things
about the entire scope of destiny lore
that we'd never
experienced before so i thought they did
a phenomenal job with that yeah i gotta
hear it man well yeah
i mean i i was constantly blown away and
honestly just getting a fact of like
trying to keep up with some of the lord
before biff's dynasty a little teaser
beforehand couldn't have been more
perfect
shout out to biff by the way if you guys
i know everybody knows who biff is but
the dynasty video had like a copyright
strike takedown it's back up if you know
anything about youtube that like kills
an algorithm really bad so go blow that
video up again because there's so much
work put into that thing some of the
cinematics they did i was just like damn
they're really really good but um shout
out necromancer field destiny suffers
from
from not have a true opposition to the
guardian fallen cabal feel more like
ally material hive and vex are
controlled doesn't feel like we have an
actual opposition to the guardians yeah
i mean that's been a problem with
destiny forever and and i was frankly
hoping that we would finally solve that
now
right because we've just we've we've
talked about not having a standing
villain for so long and it seems like we
still don't because even if
you know sabaton comes back she's not
really a true villain to us at this
point at this point she's more of a gray
character who
is always putting herself first as you
would expect her to so
uh it it's a little odd but it sounds
like we finally did get one if you beat
the campaign necromancer like we
i don't think the the uh the witness is
joining the the fast and furious family
anytime soon i don't think that's
happening uh so
yeah
um
yeah it's like anyway
we'll get to the witness in a second i
love that yeah that was perfect fast and
furious avengers family they do the same
thing they the villain always at the end
gets converted right so yeah they've
been doing that they tend to recruit
them in
um but no i mean for me it was it was
very interesting going into this
expansion that we had the interactive
trailer going all the way back to
fundament and the only time i'd ever
heard about fundament because i never
read the books of sorrow was like a bite
video to actually figure out how
everything started and i was kind of i
wasn't i hadn't really thought about it
but it makes a lot of sense because
they've never given that much backstory
to
anybody that much in our face for any
reason and when you play through the
campaign
and then you figure out about the lie
that far back in fundament and they're
basically just i mean the lie was there
to drive the proto-hive away from the
traveler in the very beginning to drive
them into the deep to drive them down to
the worms like the fact that that
whole thing from the book of sorrows was
set up that much and the lie may have
been something they like maybe they
retconned it later maybe they put it in
later because maybe that wasn't totally
like a thing but the fact that we have
that much history i mean as paul said
perfectly we have never had a character
like this because we don't have
characters that have histories
guardians are all scratched like we all
start from scratch and go forward
there's nothing behind us and the hive
from this race who they were before
you know go down into the deep and then
you get to see the leviathan that they i
mean all of the all i'm actually
thinking of bife's video now
i got those confused from the history
but yeah go watch it because it's really
good but um yes
knowing that we went that far back that
she has this history that she was told
that she was questioning what was going
on it's like tell me
and to see her motivation and then the
craziest part is when you walk in
with the bell as you were saying and you
look up
yes i'm like yes i'm sitting here
looking up and like real but i was like
i panned my camera upwards in the game
and i look up and it was just
it blew me away to see
this because we've never been that close
to it either close to it yeah i was like
the bell swing and i was like oh yeah i
remember that from the trailer and then
i looked up i was like holy crap
it was it was a moment to see what was
going on and then you're kind of working
on the spells in the background and that
goes into this whole campaign is
everything that's going on whether it's
the spells over the travel okay now you
gotta kind of warp around pick the right
door to make sure you're going through
so many things in the campaign with the
mechanics the way you got to them
kept hanging off of the story beat or
here's another cool mechanic or here's
this puzzle in the darkness and
to me
just like the traveler moment the bell
and then finally when you get done and
then the bridge appears and that is a
long walk across that bridge
yes yes so finally actually get to i
mean there's a lot that goes into that
you finally get over there i died a few
times over there because that's a little
hard on solo and eventually figured out
and i was like i wasn't sure if we were
actually gonna kill her and i was that
was the thing i was like she's got a
massive health bar this is a legit boss
fight and i think you guys phrased it
correctly because
anybody who goes through the campaign
they may not do the raid
they get the teaser of the witness which
we'll talk about in a sec but the fact
that they go through the campaign and
they get this conclusion
but there's also there's enough mystery
even if you don't know too much else
around it there's enough kind of mystery
where she's be careful what you wish for
and stuff that they left it right but
satisfying which is it's a delicate line
to walk and i think they did it very
very well
and for destiny i mean miles beyond any
campaign before but for me it's like for
a first person shooter campaign
it's
it was something else to be in your
character watching that killing kind of
killing sabathune and then just being
left in that perfect
ishii dead moment it was done very well
to me personally
absolutely i also want to give out
for now i want to give out two shout
outs um
obviously we talked about our boy what's
that what's up hive ghost he's hilarious
he's absolutely like like i thought my
new that's my new favorite character oh
yeah
the whole in the beginning they're
trusting they're not trusting then why
he ain't resonating
every visual joke in the whole game
i laugh like it is so funny and you
you're establishing this relationship
and you're like okay this is this is
cool you you know you try to gain trust
and then you're going i thought it was
cool cool uh throwbacks to
oryx you know what i'm saying and and
and no mention it was evil not much in
zevo in this one i thought she would be
a little bit more
representated representative not the
right word represented once with the
three in that little cutscene that's the
first time we've seen
i have to
my boy dj ilp clan you in there
gotta give a rest in peace shout out
officially now
my boy y'all said it wasn't going to
happen but if y'all read the law have
y'all read the law in the
yeah it's it's official oh yeah travis
is shaking his head trying to really
draft did you read it of course
so all right what you guys got to do is
when you beat the campaign
it's um one of the lore books i forget
all i know the color of it is red and
it's like martian missives or something
like that
please read it i'm going to spoil it now
so i had told people i was very
concerned
when at the end of season of the lost
when we would do the exchange for osiris
on my mind there was no way
right she's giving him back alive so we
get it the series the seat ends and it's
basically oh yeah they confirmed it tim
he's um takes him back to the ship the
whole thing i'll wait till he wakes up
he'll i'll be the first he sees blah
blah blah
we get the martian missive kado kaido
sends a message to the vanguard
we found human remains on nessus
this
matches the real osiris i don't know
what you guys have based on cabal
technology we have confirmed his remains
are here this is him then there's a
message
from osiris that he said pre-death that
goes look
she tells to the guardian
i know zavala and and and i cora mean
well but they think in the moment
i've always been a person that thinks of
the infinite future and all this other
stuff but what could happen
i willingly
gave myself
to savathune to sacrifice save dune so
she could learn yes it blew my bro
willingly
because the greater mystery is out there
i guess he's talking maybe witnesses in
the darkness right so
he is dead whoever's in saints ship
ain't osiris i i disagree
i'm loading myself i think that both
things are true
i can't load it up i'll have to take
your guesswork
i think both things are true cog i think
that osiris is dead and osiris isn't
there
it's a time travel thing right it's it's
a time it's a tribal it's a time travel
thing or it's a different osiris from a
different timeline which we now know
exists so right i think they're both
true i think sabathune took osiris from
a place where he was alive and gave him
to us but who knows if it would be our
osiris so
yeah that was that was a really cool
lore but i don't know if it changes much
because if we're still going to have
osiris in the game like you know i don't
know
we got to see we got to see read that
law book it's it's it's in it's it's the
martian message i know the book color is
red
yeah it's about cyrus is the first entry
yes this is before sabbath
yeah
yeah you got you got to read that and
then there's a if you can't continue on
there's a title message i believe it's
the second part of that book
and i was like wow okay
this is this is getting deep right here
yeah so i just thought that was
interesting again the game what i love
about it
is
when you beat the star it's still more
to do and then we even talk about mark
but i want to give it a try i've like
tried because i know you got a lot to
say about
you know what i'm saying we gotta talk
about the witness we got to talk about
the race we gotta let's get to it
yeah so um one more thing about the
campaign before we move on uh we've
we've also talked about like basically
the ending of the campaign which was
fantastic and and so well done whether
or not you agree with them killing uh
killing sabbath it was absolutely like a
great
i will say like i we didn't want them to
kill it kill her
but they couldn't have done it any
better i don't think yeah absolutely
that's my thing is like the journey to
where they got was it fantastic it still
doesn't fix the problem of destiny not
really having an ongoing villain but i
feel like now they have the opportunity
to build up the witness for the next two
years and i'm sure that they'll do that
um but
the
the other thing is along the campaign
there were also other story beats that
were so fantastic
learning learning that sabbath didn't
know didn't remember who she was when
she got resurrected and like that she
used us to help her remember like that
was a great story be there there were so
many beats that were fine i'm slightly
confused about that one though cause
like
how
like when crow was resurrected he was
like a totally different person with
like no memories so like i get that she
forgot like those key events that we
reminded her of but like she was still
like
flying around her throne world like
attacking us and like she wasn't just
like a brand new baby
well we don't know that for sure because
i don't think we ever see
sabbathune
not in an elusive form until the very
end of the game that's at least my
understanding and that so i'm thinking
that maybe she created false versions of
herself to go on like a a pre-determined
path while she sort of was hiding out
somewhere trying to figure things out
that's right that's my my guess
examine it more carefully yeah yeah i
think there's probably lore for it but
either way it was a cool reveal because
i was just like oh yeah i forgot about
that rule she shouldn't remember
anything if she was actually forgetting
about that yeah i think that's fantastic
but um
let's talk about the coolest part of the
story in my opinion which is the extra
cut scene we got at the end they
introduced the witness properly for
those of you who have been reading lore
the witness has been a character forever
in the game of the final shape he is the
uh he is on the side of of the darkness
uh also a collector of
civilizations as you can see in the
trailer um
and uh i think this is
without a doubt like the final the final
boss or is this the final boss or is it
is this
it's not darkness itself it's someone
who wears darkness like a cloak or
something like that yeah like so i i am
also a little confused about whether
this is like
lieutenant darkness or like boss
i think so but like i also i also kind
of maintained that like my theory before
this was that the darkness wouldn't have
a fixed form like it wouldn't be a new
looking alien race it would like take
over at cora or someone but
clearly that is not true because there
is this new
entirely unique looking like i again i i
i would assume he is
maybe part of a race of other people
that look like that or
maybe not because they they there's also
lore about how
the darkness would be like a singular
entity and it wouldn't have like a bunch
of light bearers like what's with his
head it never ends
okay yeah we need to talk about the
character design so i i love the silent
hill
like smoke head thing that was extremely
cool
disrespectful
the very anime very like you know pixar
looking
destiny is such good character design in
like every other aspect that like that
was just really it was such a big reveal
moment too it's the first new race in
all of destiny history and it's like
now we got to take him kind of
they don't work they're biscuits
either they're just right every scale
right he's right
but like so
the design was was off-putting to me i i
like the cut scene i think it's a huge
story moment i like the witness
introduces a character but
again maybe we just need to see him out
of a cut scene or maybe he's wears a
helmet most of the time
we gotta keep all that going on i i so i
paul i'm gonna
i'm gonna repeat your words back to you
and see try to make an argument for this
because i generally agree with you but
i've i've debated this with other people
since and kind of in the middle now okay
you said that you were unsettled by its
appearance and i kind of think that's
what they were going for not necessarily
scary or relatable but something that
you couldn't really even like nail down
because it's so foreign and that's
always been the darkness's vibe and i
kind of like that that you're just like
okay what's up with this person like
they seem to like move in a different
way from time or like you see their
hands move like irregularly you see that
weird head thing that's like an
incomprehensible kind of smoke for a
face and then even the eyes aren't
really what you're expecting when you
see the face the face is like
a cartoonish mirror of like a human's
face and
the first thing that i thought was
that's kind of a weird face and then i
thought on it more and i was like it
kind of bothered me and i think maybe
that that's what they were going for
they just they didn't want to be another
uncomfortable scary monster they kind of
wanted it to someone just know like it
felt like a different art style entirely
than destiny like it felt like it was
like clone wars animation in destiny you
know what i mean like because it was
cartoony it was an animal yeah it's like
more cartoony like that the eyes just do
that it's it's more cartoony in a way
that we haven't seen from destiny before
all the other things you're talking
about the time and the smokehead it has
two different voice tracks there's a
male and female voice track playing
simultaneously which i think is
interesting um
but like all of that was great it's just
just the look i i i don't know again
we'll see more of it in the future but
it just it didn't really match to me
all of the the pyramid architecture and
stuff we've seen okay i didn't even
think we'd see its face honestly i
thought i thought it would just be like
uh
so i was i wasn't expecting them to turn
around either but i know i don't know i
i will still challenge that like the
fact that it goes against the art style
and goes against what you're saying yeah
it's all that stuff i still think
there's an advantage there in like
like just it makes you ask so many
questions i feel like that i don't know
i what if it what about bungie's new ip
that's their new that's their new art
style that's the cinnamon that's
actually not the idea that's not the
witness that we put the wrong cinematic
in sorry guys
um
i i kind of i kind of don't think it's
gonna be lieutenant darkness i kind of
think it's gonna be boss darkness
because my my impression is the same as
yours paul as a fellow lore guy i i
don't think the darkness has a boss i
think the darkness just is right like
even the traveler i don't think is the
light really it's just like it's kind of
the equivalent of what the witness is
for the darkness it it wears the light
like a cloak in the same way that the
the witness wears the dark and so i
think at some point both of these
characters have to be taken out so that
we can continue to use light and
darkness freely and the sandbox of
destiny can continue without destroying
the sources of these powers and so i
think that the witness is thanos in this
mcu-like world they're building and i
think the the wit or the uh the traveler
is the other end of that and i think
probably the traveler dies in lightfall
the witness dies in the final shape and
then we get
both kind of forms of power
so no no witnesses raid boss huh
i don't think so i i i don't think so
either honestly i think
they're already setting up a witness as
lieutenant actually it's in one of the
the side quests that happens afterward
where they talk about
kind of like a second person there did
you guys play that mission yet i didn't
play which one which one which which
measures i can't remember i've played so
much destiny i don't know which one it
is but it's blurry they introduce
another character that's like this is a
well this is the yeah i assume it's
going to be scorn i mean it's a scoring
raid yeah
it's going to be because they're the
other side
i think they're going to bait and switch
i think the first half will be scoring
because they're like attacking and then
i think the second half we get a preview
of the new
the new mob that's what i think i hope
so i i just feel like
i've been let down i think by the last
couple of raid bosses like i could have
sworn that clove spray would be the boss
of db's
yeah and then i started then it was
which i don't love that decision
honestly still like it's a good grade
but um and then in uh garden of
salvation it's just some freaking big
minotaur i
i i don't know i i keep
guessing wrong on those and like so
whatever i i think and hopefully i feel
like it's not gonna be that i feel like
it's just going to be like a giant scorn
monster that has some sort of lore
attached to it that that is my guess for
now e i got to get your opinion on this
you gotta i need you to witness your
thought the art style the thing
everything which would you know i mean i
first off never expected us to see
anything related to there's always been
the hint of the veil since d1 concept
art
it's going back that far the shadowy
figure and then i'm going kind of
shadowy figure armor that's kind of
moving head that never stops girl and
like
all and i couldn't honestly tell if like
what was in the background you said it
was the witness as a gather of like
civilizations i didn't know if that was
like all the moons of like fundament
either though so i couldn't quite tell
if that's what it was yeah so that makes
more sense the witness according to the
lord used to be a collector of societies
and isn't anymore gotcha and the new
rabbit challenges out of space
new rat and chat was saying the witness
was once immortal and if that's the case
that could lead into
the fact that it has some shape
now granted you can't see below here so
you get to see the eyes you don't get to
see anything down here what's under it
it could be the whole men in black where
it's like here and then there's this
little dude underneath obviously that's
not it but
um
i think travis actually phrased it
fairly well it was
like unsettling off-putting
uncomfortable it was weird
because you guys described like the the
eyes were strange but like i couldn't
look away
um i was trying to figure out what like
was it a jawline what's with like the
kind of forehead line
still don't understand what's going on
with the hair that is
not
it's the what's on the top of the head
that continues you have to personify it
the smoke
here
um yeah
i i mean same with you guys like i was
completely thrown off did not expect it
didn't see it coming thought the walk
away would be this one and you just see
this figure and i was like
yeah it's like that's exactly what i
figured and then the turn i was like um
and then you saw it and
i'm kind of with you guys i wasn't sure
how to take it but as you guys were
saying
i think the idea of everything we have
is like it's so rigid and you see all
the detail in kaidel's armor and it's
like it is the antithesis of
what we know it is this weird anime eye
kind of flowy always a little vibey
which is weird because they're all about
the triangle which is all hard shapes
and the travelers around and yet the
representation is like we're all rigid
and apparently they're more there could
be more fluid in a sense like just as
the back and forth between the two
hearing you guys talk about it basically
sells me on it more as you guys have
been sitting here debating to say if it
is the other side of the equation or
however you want to light versus dark
and all of those other pieces it is
weird enough that it makes sense to me
yeah and i think that's great i just
brought it up now as we're watching i
still like it
the smoke should have started at the
eyes okay that would have been like
really unsettling and weird to just have
like smoke head from there it's just i
can't i can't do the eyes i can't get
over here listen
now he looks like thane from mass effect
that i'm looking at yeah they got a
little thing in them yeah they got a
little guy i get yeah little thing i can
see that sorry they do
they do yeah yeah yeah they do i mean if
he wasn't finished then i'll go no i
mean that's most for me it was just the
fact that
it was unexpected
and and i've played through it i'm going
to play through it a couple more times
because i've been getting close to
seeing it again and just every every
time i think about that image
i i kind of want to interact with it
more and i'm curious when we're going to
get to and as you guys are talking about
you have lightfall and final shape
lightfall seems extremely telling in
tidal as you guys are talking about is
it the fall of the light is it the
separation between the two is the
darkness coming in
maybe we don't have access to the
traveler which would and that's the
weird thing it's like you think at some
point the traveler is going to go away
they're not going to put all this effort
in and this is where you like the game
mechanics have to ground some of the
story where it could be a little crazier
we're not going to get rid of arc 3.0
and um
what solar 3.0 like three months after
we get the final one in
find like lightfall or even final shape
i don't feel like they're gonna do that
so again i wonder is it like travis said
where eventually we're going to
be the embodiment of both light and dark
and we are the one that walk in the gray
and both of these fall
that would make some sense more yeah um
yeah they have to do that if they want
to continue destiny to pass
it's call of duty now we just don't have
any powers we just only have to do this
we can't double jump anymore yeah so
it's one of those weird moments where
you're like
i you know you can go as wandering as
you want and you're like they still have
to make a game function after this and
you can kind of like try and take it
from there but overall the look
i think i don't love it or hate it i
think i'm just more intrigued to
understand more about it and i hope we
don't have to wait a year to get
anything else from this little like tiny
little clip before next year that's my
hope
i don't think so i think this whole year
again is going to be building up the
lightfall the way we built up the witch
queen so i think we're going to have a
lot more this i mean this expansion was
more darkness than i thought it was
going to be there's a whole mission and
a pyramid ship i thought that was just
going to be the raid did you guys like
this
[ __ ] oh there's a there's a europa
mission like yeah we're gonna like run a
strike backwards or something like
a whole mission and a pyramid like that
is really unexpected so there's a lot
more darkness
you said the next year of destiny and i
think you meant to say 18 months maybe
which i i don't care if if we get
another which queen quality level
expansion i am yeah i'll fight for it i
have elders i have to catch up on
elden ring
god of war i got other stuff to play i
got a child
yeah
i agree i think that um i i guess i'm
i'm i'm not with my boy paul on this one
but i understand his your thought
process because it's like yo when you
look at it you're not like afraid of
that entity right and i understand it is
it is really different than what they
used to but i think that's the
difference is what i like about it it
just feels alien it just i think the
thing for me is i remember
garden of salvation raid ending
and the conversation talking and i'm
going to assume
this is witness talk during that time
and um you know where they kind of have
you looking at yourself and talking to
yourself and one of you yeah the
daughters or whatever and i just
it's just the unknown aspect of it and i
like it different you know from the the
shadow we think i thought it was going
to be exact representation of the shadow
we figured that we would see in the deep
stone crypt the statue that you always
see the hooded thing the veil the arm i
thought it's going to be that kind of a
witch kind of vibe and this was just
different and
the ominous part to me wasn't
being afraid of the character for
to me the ominous part was i mean yes
the smoke was fire but
when i saw the ships behind
and i saw like it felt like
some someone who is in control or the
lieutenant
of something that is conquering
civilizations like they are going
through and you are next on the list to
be assimilated
right and and that's why it excited me
because i was like
in a way if it is true law wise like did
savithoon help avert this assimilation
at one point right now they gonna have
to explain the hell out of that
of how she did that you know
we know that's there's a lot of
questions and holes there or certain on
certain levels that they got to clear up
but the idea of that overarching threat
with sabbathun now this gray moral
character that has been now chosen by
the light
that part excited me but i'm with you on
the r styles party it is it is
completely different but i think i was
okay with it it's just one shot i mean
i'll give it more of a chance so if we
see different angles but i i don't know
i think the shrouded figure the statue
is much more intimidating and like
mysterious this whole time but
i will say that that's what's underneath
the shroud off at some point though you
can't fight it oh i know you might find
a blanket i do want to say that i was
expecting what you guys were talking
about those when it goes into what's
after the campaign and depending on how
much of that you've gotten into
we mara's still here mario is in full
force
hilarious see what the parasite quest
please somebody just like give me more
i'm dying
the first time it started talking i just
burst out laughing like oh my god it's
actually specially glitched
that was amazing but when you guys were
tying into the witness it's the point
where mara and i probably don't remember
the line correctly
somewhere i guess on all of her other
worldly travels when she talks about a
voice that she has heard louder than any
other that basically like sounded like
it talked into her soul
when she's talking about it sounds like
she may have heard from the witness as
well so her
connection to all of this
went off in her infinite throne world
and then she's sitting here now standing
as we you know put the little hive worm
in a gun type thing which is hilarious
but more the implicat implications
behind everything that's going on
mara has these contingency plans
when we're on her list of her hit list
of like people by the way yeah last
resort
i was like mara's batman she's got prep
time and she has plans to uh
how to kill everyone in case they turn
bad that is literally batman yeah yes
yes shout out tomorrow she could do it
too i believe her
hate her she's my least favorite
character by far she became my least
favorite character by the end of season
of the loss i don't know she got a
little bit she got a little better i
think in the conclusion after she's like
was outsmarted clearly and paul her plan
was to kill him with a knife that was
hilarious i laughed when she pulled out
the knife i'm like you were going to
stab sabotage in the face that was your
plan
yeah that was her genius don't worry i
got the the the queen of eyes i got her
i got a knife deeply confusing i was
like
somehow i gotta give her a little more
credit but yeah that definitely kind of
questions your motives if you all you
got to knife but she's also throwing
this entire like half god wave at you
know oryx's ship
and then she's sitting here with a knife
that was weird to see at the end and
everything but now it's
it is it's really cool to get these
interactions not a lot of them and i
think as you said cog the whole thing it
would be cool to see more of the
characters on our side of things
throughout the missions that we've been
going through yeah we actually got to
see mara at the kind of tail end of her
stuff that we were talking to but i mean
you've got shacks of all anna like we
didn't hear any words from all the
people
say one word most of them
mostly
did not get anywhere we're getting at
least one anna rasputin season this year
please please
i almost guarantee that's happening so i
think we'll definitely see morgana i
talked to the voice actress and she
really strongly
into that
that anna would be coming back so i will
say zavala lance riddick killed hit that
tower scene oh yeah like i've never seen
him that like that emotive for zavala
was really cool just to see the level
and the nikora coming in but yeah
there's an entire room of people who
don't say a damn thing and i was like
can we get a little more with some of
these just some discussion but i was
like it's a cheap availability yeah it's
like it's a cheap 14 touch to shoulder
so yeah
there was not a lot of changes in
animations there's no like hugging
moving it's just like kind of static
models mostly
it looked cool and again
it absolutely was the focus and nailed
it but
yeah i will definitely say that was it's
been cool to see what's post campaign
because you've got those like
reflections interactions in the portal
the voicemails as you have voicemails
from sabathoon it's about the memories
i mean
did you guys see the two truths or two
truths and two lies oh my god i've been
wondering about that all day
all right i can't remember i still i
still remember them
i don't think this is very spoilery if
you haven't seen it yet but okay so
you have to do
this is kind of weird because like you
have to do like a separate memory
mission that is separate from the other
ones that's just on the map just click
on the node and do it and you just it's
just a little encounter and like you've
done with the other memory things and
you kill things and then
uh steve within shows up and he's like
she wants to play two truths and two
lies and she says four things and two of
them are true and two of them are not
true
okay travis you have to help me remember
all of them one of them is that
the
other planets io mercury and titan are
in saboten's care
correct that is a statement
uh
what was the one about the witness
uh the wit
uh
uh so the the the three planets that
still are gone are in sabbath's care
the sabathune returned mars to us was
the second thing that she said
the third thing was you will soon gain
the power to oh yeah uh
to uh move
make planets appear and reappear at will
to i thought it was to move i thought i
said like to move things between worlds
like the thing basically that you think
you can make planets available or not
available which is crazy and then the
fourth one is the taking king shall
return
okay i've got them actually verbatim so
yeah taking king will rise again
the power the power to move worlds will
soon be yours
yes we'll move worlds the witness
returned to mars to your solar system
the witness returns that's the the
witness and then mercury io titan are in
my care
correct and i wow
what do you think i think the two that
are correct are
that the witness returned mars to us
that we will soon gain the power to move
worlds
so you don't think we're getting king's
fallback
i don't think the witness one's true
because he didn't really seem like he
was
doing a lot like like or wanting to be
involved until the very end but what's
with the relic in the enclave and kind
of basically the enclave looks like the
darkness ship architecture
yeah to a point for the whole weapon
crafting area that was they're like this
wasn't here before no that's true
actually okay never mind baby
and also the darkness we know from
season of uh
the
arrival that the darkness did take it
like that was canon and so it's it's
possible that savithoon returned it to
us and that she used some magic but i
tend to think there's a better chance of
that i i think the taking king rising
again if we get kings fall back i don't
think that'll be canon because it's the
exact same thing it's not like yeah like
the legends haven't been
oryx is gonna come back and then be like
oh and i'm gonna let you kill me the
same way you did last time like i just
don't think that's going to happen the
legendaries are fun but they're not
story yeah and then sabathune having the
other planets seems very low stakes to
me so i think it's those two which would
be the most surprising
i feel like both the sabbathun one and
the witness one can't be true because
like
if i feel like it's gotta be one or the
other because why correct yeah that
power be split that would be super
boring if that was it yeah
yeah
i said i gotta get to that one that's a
good one yeah it's really short it's
just like essentially one encounter
really i think yeah it's i don't know if
there's like a bunch of these i don't
know how many there are but i was
surprised to see that because you do if
you do two of those a week it's like a
powerful engram or something so like
it's telling you to do them which is a
little weird but
uh yeah it took me a little while to
even find that
yeah
thanks for bringing that up paul i i was
like on the top of my list of things to
talk about and i do a whole video on
that eventually nice yeah they got a lot
of law man what do you think the power
to move worlds could be i've been
thinking that it's like
i think it's the shroud i think it's
what it's what shrouded the world
because like i don't think they're just
like in a bunch of clouds i think they
were pulled somewhere like another
dimension or something like you know the
dude in the ship has got all the planets
hanging around right i think literally
like those could be
shrouded we should actually examine
those planets to see if like type one of
them is mars
oh is it okay because you could you was
wondering if like mercury and io and
stuff would be in there too
you can see the tears through time as
one at one of the planets like it's it's
like mars with like tears of oh it's
that one okay yeah yeah yeah because i
remember seeing that one so maybe he
maybe those aren't literal planets maybe
he was just like observing
representation of the planet or like a
hologram or whatever he's a collector so
they could have right
yeah so maybe those are taken for
specific reasons or something but that's
what i imagine the power to like move
worlds is and like i don't know maybe
earth will be
moved at some point but
yeah i don't know
weird look
obsession with collecting things is the
witness teddy
you
[Laughter]
i was one of her previous guests
shout out to teasing teddy i know teddy
no
so
i wanted to ask you guys have you seen
the helm redesign
kind of like work around like basically
the way it kind of changed the ball
themed one yeah so like there was again
i never know if this was a thing it
looks more and more like that is going
to be kind of our
one of our permanent structures if we
ever lose the tower or ever lose
our connection to earth and easy to see
because now it looks like the windows
even have like blast shields on them and
there's always this [ __ ] i mean yeah
it's like there's the room right that's
that thing is a ship
if that thing ever has to depart
that seems when you guys are talking
about planets coming and going or things
like that if we're ever going to lose
edz and kind of the tower or anything
like that it does seem like that they
slowly might be building us up to as you
said moving worlds around well if that
actually happens then it does seem like
they're slowly making the helm kind of
more of a permanent place for all that
stuff to happen
i i think we're going to leave the solar
system um
maybe not before final shape maybe
that'll be the next phase but i think
that's definitely the plan to lead the
solar system at some point and go
i don't know effects home worlds like
darkness
they're running out of devices to go so
exactly yeah that's what i mean
yeah it makes sense yeah i'm curious to
see just a couple of loose end
characters obviously the stranger you
know there's a couple questions i want
to see how they handle a lot of stuff in
the future we talked about you know
anime break
i know so it's like
we just got to see where i want to know
where they go with that they're setting
up
saladin i love the conversation
with zavala and saladin
about how he
mentored him and how wild zavala used to
be because saladin clearly does not like
crow like it is so hilarious how he's
just like i don't even know why we're
dealing with him you know you know his
past and everything and he was like look
i was that guy you took me under you
know what i mean so please be the mentor
because i'm still
i feel like my only let's say the little
nitpick is like to me crow should be
advancing a little bit more and i feel
he got set back with the sabbath thing
it's in my eyes i'm assuming he was
always going to eventually be the vet
the hunter vanguard so i still think
he's going to be i think it's just it's
taking longer and i thought i'd take it
along with this i'm like when is he
because my only thing is it's just
getting to that point with every major
cataclysmic event it's just icora and
zavala and there's nothing and that's
great and we love them but the hunters
need that shine it's time you know so
that's where i want to know where that
goes and what i will say even though i
said all that about zavala and um i did
love
icora questioning herself for the first
time and i love that um finch was like
well wait is she's the great spy she's
the one that got you guys found out and
she's the re like i love like he's so
matter-of-fact with it you're a great
got fooled so how could we choose like i
i love that component and that dynamic
of it was hilarious to me so yeah it was
good man
the story was great it's so much here
the narrative team man they did it they
really did it i i really can't i'm just
nitpicking at this point they really
told a fantastic story
yeah
so raid predictions are
scorn
mostly and then maybe uh maybe they
break off a preview of the remix when it
comes to uh
to what's going on with the witness and
the darkness maybe at least in the boss
i feel like there's got to be loosen
hive champion or like oh there are
guardians in there it'd be a little
weird to not have them
be in there at all yeah the fact that we
have an artifact that is based around
suppression
is heavily going to lean into the fact
that that's going to be one of the
better ways to manage the guardians
because if you get a couple of those
in a room in an encounter and there's
like multiple supers going off you're
going to be dropping people left and
right if they're not suppressed
so you said the glaive being able to
suppress just with a projectile is going
to be able to hopefully keep those guys
while they are guardian
level type enemies at least at bay from
supers because the supers
catch one of those titan shields coming
at you yeah they will definitely take
your head clean off so those
and then again the knives that's what i
want to say when you're talking about it
before yeah this seems like a preview of
solar 3.0 when we got to see if this is
what blade barrage could be
throw the knives up in the air and then
you can kind of cast where you want it
or maybe they're like auto tracking and
go i would love to actually see this be
a preview of what kind of
the rework of hive could be and if
that's like the animation of what the
knives are like they're massive by the
way
they are massive massive knives that
they throw at you and you take one
you're like that's like most of the
screen
the hive go hard with their knives
they love swords
like two shields like they double up on
basically everything we do except i feel
like the wizards got a little hose they
don't seem nearly as the wizards aren't
very good yeah i've never really
struggled just they're hard they're
they're just hard to find
yeah around but they're not i don't know
i i never was killed by a hype wizard i
was killed by plenty of knights and
accolades yeah
yeah the shield throws weren't too bad
to dodge but yeah the knives ever
stopped and peeked my head out and i
just took one straight to the dome
it was over pretty fast
i am very curious that they can one shot
you with their suits
i mean yeah it it makes sense it's
actually the i mean because we do it to
them all the damn time so it is actually
really nice
um do you guys
finale outside of it
do you guys have a favorite
mission
um
i don't know if i remember them well
enough so many i like literally just
finished all of them i mean
it's hard to top i think the very last
mission with sabathune i just
like environment wise
storytelling wise i think it was i i
like undoing the
the curse and stuff like it's not a very
combat intensive part but i just think
revealing the story to her like during
the middle of the fight um
yeah it's a very memorable mission it's
yeah the opposite of whatever whatever
panoptis was and
uh
cyrus right this is how you
not a great fight
no you're right i suppose i think you
know what it is
yeah it looks it look cool i i got to
give it to that one too because while
the you know savage witches are weaving
the spell
and the lie is revealed for the first
time you see her character break yeah oh
yeah you think this yeah you think this
is the truth like and i love that
because she's so used to being in
control and being one step ahead and
then you see it and i'm like okay yeah
it's so many man it oh they did a good
job like i did like the the one with the
um
the guy in the in the circle pit that
one was cool i like the one i forgot
about the ahamkara that was awesome
yeah and it took me way too long to
figure out what i was supposed to be
doing yeah it was like it took me a
minute precision shot in the mouth is
like very small so i was like i was
shooting it but it was always immune and
it's only active for a short period of
time so i'm like i don't know what's
going on with this i was wandering
around for like 20 minutes the first
time i did yeah that took longer than
i'd probably say i'd probably
not like i collected out immediately of
course you didn't yep no question you
know why because i just refused to
accept it was immune i just kept
shooting it and i was like oh i'm doing
damage now
that's something that has to work
i could hear i could hear destin looking
around for stuff and i was just shooting
in its mouth and i was like oh i'm doing
damage let's just shoot it yeah yeah
good try your favorite mission what's
your favorite one
um i mean yeah i kind of agree with the
consensus that it's the last one but the
first mission where you meet finch is
amazing i i really really like that just
the whole going to the uh the throne
world for the first time was really
really great
um i like the mission where you find out
about the lie
that's the mission before the final one
and i think that's where is that also
the mission with the ankara i think it
might be um it's the con
i think that's actually probably my
favorite one because i was just like
juiced and i was ready to go to the
final battle the final battle was a
little bittersweet for me because that
mission was the one that took me the
longest to get through on the hardware i
was playing with
with a full set of people and one of
them i think it's harder with more
people
yeah it was way harder with three people
for me because one of my players was a
brand new destiny player still figuring
things out
and the other one was destined legary so
i okay no fire team i was soloing that
basically
i'm gonna scale difficulty
there goes that guest spot
no but i will say i played with uh new
rad block wings they're sitting in chat
right now because black wings was trying
to finish up the legendary and he's like
hey can you guys come in and help me
so i jump in and all of a sudden
normally it's the wizards that are
sitting that you're rotating for that
buff
and now you shoot one and it's not dead
i'm like why are you not dead you should
be dead right now i just blasted you
with a rocket and you're not dead so
just the fact that that happened we
eventually rockets on wizards
shoot him with stun glaze whack them
with the glaive
that's all i did i did that six times no
solo solo
like solo had no problem like our
ballista you saw the difference yeah no
solo
i died that was like getting caught out
of position between a super and a couple
enemies i was like yeah i get that one
but once i kind of got a feel and got
some positioning and rotation around you
know eventually ended up getting by
myself and it was a good challenge but
yeah with the three people
i was doing the damage i was doing
before i was like that health bar is not
moving that fast yeah it was you know
what i noticed and i know we're getting
towards the end here but like
one thing just overall with the campaign
i think one of the core reasons the
difficulty works the way it does and why
no one was complaining about it what was
missing from the legend version of the
campaign
champions champions suck this is why i
can go and post my glaive evangelism and
i have 50 people telling me they're
loadouts and they're all different and
that is something you just cannot do
in nightfalls or in uh hard mode raids
because you need the specific things and
it's always like some stupid primary you
don't want to use usually and whatever
one weapon they've picked to be the good
weapon for the point and i i cannot like
now they're they're putting champions in
the story missions is part of the the
master and legend so there aren't
champions now
i don't think that's going to be as fun
no because we're not going to be able to
use my same loadout again you know what
they don't do they should just make mods
that are called like shield breaker
overload breaker and just make it like
five or
six points make it cost like six points
that way it has to take up most of your
slot and everybody can just load up one
of those and it works with anyone at
that point it's like why even have like
i don't think champions are necessarily
a good route to go with difficulties
yeah you're right i think that if if i
could snap my finger and remove it from
the game i would that's what i mean
though like maybe this should be the
design philosophy going forward because
you know they change enemy density
they have the hard power cap which keeps
you under yeah they have uh interesting
fights with hive guardians that are
unique they have mechanically
interesting puzzles and bosses
and all of these things combined
together to be like there's the
difficulty whereas like champions are
like
do you have the champion thing no i mean
that's literally your gauntlets you may
as well go to grasp of everest get the
triple slot equip all three and you just
forget about your gauntlets because it's
just taking care of champions and then
you can pick about four different
weapons as well no i mean that's yeah
because i mean
you phrased it perfectly because
that is one of the things like hey when
i was doing i'm working on solo guides
with a hunter and no exotics just like
the least survivable class i could think
of for pve
and i'm going you don't have to worry
about champions you just need to survive
typically be able to work from range
except for the dark mission because
there's a lot of things and just try and
be aware of your surroundings but as you
said the enemy density like the i was
just going through the
um
pyramid ship the mission on the pyramid
ship on europa there are so many cabal
that spawn in waves in there it is but
you can do
it sitting there plinking them all with
arrows and going through
you know shoot a rocket at the boss get
a damage phase and that's that was a
point that i
for whatever reason i didn't hate the
like damage phases it did not feel like
the hollowed lair strike so i'm going
like damage like oh and and i hit
another wall it's like you got the big
boss bar you know it's kind of getting
down and then a huge wave comes out but
you also have something to do
so it makes sense you have like the
mechanics the boss densities you get the
density
and then like the hive guardians yeah
give me more unique enemies to fight the
champions that just like oh you looked
at him wrong and then but we didn't even
mention the best part
overload is broken
yeah it's broken all right
i don't even i haven't even messed with
that yet
yeah i i think the the short version is
they they but now they've got the hive
guardians which serve as a perfect foil
for instead of champions like an
interesting enemy type and they've got
mechanics inside activities which now
they should just use that to increase
difficulty i think i think paul's right
like that that's the new
game design like they should they should
just follow that philosophy with all of
their stuff going forward and i think
now if there's any ex if they had any
excuse before to not put mechanics in
tight inside casual stuff like they're
gone like they need to just do it this
is proof this is proof yeah because i
know i know paul's got to wrap up but
it's like the thing that is really cool
for me where i got to get them they
flowers i agree with everything guys
said it proved with mechanics and good
interesting enemies and everything you
don't need to rely on champion stuff for
difficulty but i want to give them their
flowers for the legendary campaign
for a power level technique so if you if
you challenge yourself you put it on
that difficulty you can now get yourself
the double drops and then up to the cap
to be ready so i like that so now it it
added more value to the campaign and now
you and then to your point trav and we
we're looking at the um the glaive and
there's other things where they're
rewarding you for re-running the
campaign by uh increasing that bar so
it's good stuff all around and i i want
to give them they really did their job
with that stuff fantastic though yeah i
mean that's
yeah the fact that there's a reason to
play the campaign again again the
champions are going to be annoying but
you can get reputation the fact that
it's worthy to replay at all
that's probably the biggest thing why
would you want to replay it because
these are really really fun encounters
and as you said the rewards as you go
through at some point i'm guessing the
double just chest may not be as
rewarding once we hit like 1550 but it's
still that was the fact that we went to
1520 and here's your infusion fodder
here's and it's not here's the infusion
fodder and no upgrade modules they're
like and the upgrade modules yeah we're
gonna throw them at you as you go and it
just great job all the way through i
played 12 hours straight
on stream
and i literally had no complaints for
the entire time
the whole way through it was
like a wonderful journey from start to
finish yeah i probably bought a few
upgrade modules because i was doing
legendary unknown but
outside of that literally
i will i will t i will take the upgrade
modules but that was for legend and solo
and i did it but
i will definitely say like
so much of that could have been done
just going through and it would have
been a challenge probably more without
my loadout but i'm proving you can do it
without
i don't know i i've had such a good time
these last couple of days turned out
tassy the legend thank you for taking
the time with us brother i know you got
to run i know you got it right thanks
for having me you know i appreciate it
this has been my biggest longest
discussion and i'm happy to have it with
you guys always man it's always fun man
you know where could the fine people
find you i hate to rush because i know
the boy gotta go
just uh
on twitter and you can google me for my
articles
another one
we made it i know we actually got to
just the fact that we're post witch
queen launch after this thing it's
couldn't have had a better group to talk
to with all of you guys today like this
is this is a good collective minds to
bounce everything around and post witch
queen and then
fall out right before was except like i
know back to back episodes just
greatness thank you everybody who's been
in chat and listening if you enjoy the
show wherever you find it in video or
audio like
five star reviews apple spotify all
those things but also for me
you guys have been just extremely
supportive lately with the content and
everything so i just want to thank all
of you guys as well it's been just great
so far uh travis what about you are you
reviewing elder ring now you get to go
off and do that i'm not reviewing elden
ring i will probably not get around to
elgin ring until like next month because
who has time for that with destiny out
um but yeah you can read my review in
progress of destiny 2 the witch queen
tomorrow at some point
i'm actually writing it tonight so after
this i got to go to that cocktail party
and then after that i've got to write
through
um uh my review will be in progress uh
by the end of uh day tomorrow and then
my final review will happen the day
after the raid so that'll be march 6th
on sunday um it probably won't be live
until monday realistically because i
have an editor who has to read it and he
doesn't work weekends but uh yeah uh it
should be it should be ready to go right
after the raid and we have a full
assessment other than that you can
follow me on twitter at thai guy travis
you can read all the reviews and
previews i've been doing the past couple
weeks on ngn.com and uh you can support
my fellow friends here including
potassium who may or may not be in an
episode of fire team chat tomorrow we'll
see
hey ign getting popping off in the
destiny content look at this
no doubt you already know me lord
cognito on twitter iron was podcast
defining duke all that good stuff man
another great show shout out to the chat
everybody was fantastic this is fun
y'all we're in the mix we're in the
grind raid next week i'm ready let's go
yeah all right well for everybody in
chat you guys have been amazing
christopher sharp you are the mvp of the
evening um for all of you guys host who
joined us today tassie thank you for
taking the time let you go sorry and um
for this episode number 186 february
24th post with queen it has been
the last word